good morning everybody um before we
start our public hearings this morning
if you would all please um rise to join
I'm going to open the public hearing for
House Bill 59 and welcome representative
legislation thank you madam chair and
members of Criminal Justice and Public
Safety representative Dennis Manion
rocking M25
Salem this bill here before you is uh
similar to a bill that was filed last
year by chairman Roy um he
had he had it in two parts so he had one
bill with this bill and the bill that's
going to follow this so I separated them
into two separate bills what this bill
essentially does is
ADD language in the RSA under first
degree assault and second degree assault
adding a subsection talking about
causing serious knowingly causing
serious bodily injury to a uh Public
Safety official that would include law
enforcement paid firefighters on call
Firefighters EMS Personnel uh in raising
the penalty in the situation which a
first-degree assault to a class A
misdemeanor and then in the
section that applies to second degree of
salt it would be knowingly or recklessly
causing bodily inur injury or
unprivileged physical contact to the
same people law enforcement officer paid
firefighter volunteer on call
firefighter or EMS people um
so obviously in today's culture there's
a lot of anti- police
uh rhetoric going on and this is a way
for us to protect our Public Safety
people not just law enforcement but EMS
and Fighters as well from assault while
they're uh in the course of their their
Duty um the bottom section of this bill
talks about extended term of
imprisonment we added that this year
because it will remove a similar section
in that part of the statute uh so there
are certain crimes that you can petition
for extended terms of imprisonment this
is one of them for an enhanced penalty I
think it's cleaner being in the sections
of first degree and second degree
assault because uh it clearly defines
what the penalty should be in it um and
for the extended term of imprisonment
there are
some things you need to do before that
applies you need to obviously notify the
defendant beforehand that you intend to
cleaner thank
you thank you representative Manion
representative
pette I just have a question um does
this Encompass both M Municipal and
private as far as
EMS I believe it would so if you're if
you're private EMS and I don't know
there are some private EMS that also
work for municipal agencies um so I
would imagine it would apply to
you representative
lels thank you for taking my question um
would public servants such as
ourselves be included in
that not as I read it
no okay do you think they
should follow up I'm sorry um in a if
you want to file a separate bill on that
but I think this
specifically uh encompasses our Public
Safety people who deal with this on a
daily basis thank
you representative Newman yeah I just
have a question to follow on on your
question um about the the other the paid
private um emss and stuff like that and
whenever you have a list you're apt to
leave somebody out and I'm wondering if
a more inclusive phrase might be
appropriate to say like in first
responders for instance list them and so
you'd get the the people that are in the
list and put some more inclusive term in
there
that may maybe more broadly defines what
those people do so that if you missed
one you just don't have a list you have
also an inclusive phrase I don't know
what that would be but maybe First
Responders would be it or or or just
make the definition be positions like so
that you're not Li it to just that list
so so there is a list actually in the
statute uh but this language was taken
from the existing statute under RSA 6516
extended term of imprisonment and it's
subsection G that says almost the same
exact language and that that list that's
in the in current statute is the list
that we used to create uh this bill okay
thank you
representative
Muse thanks for taking my question um
how does the bill uh address situations
and I know this comes up frequently not
just for EMS Personnel but for police
and firefighters as well but encounters
with people who e are either having a a
mental health crisis or who are under
the influence of a drug that
dramatically Alters their behavior like
PCP or something like that
so in the situation where it's mental
health uh this this
knowingly is a high standard a coupable
state of mind to uh reach um so if
someone were to be charged with that
obviously that would be taken into
consideration during trial um as far as
somebody on under the influence of
alcohol or drugs that's not considered
the defense in New Hampshire for any
Newman thank
you and just to comment on that these
penalties are not mandatory minimum so
therefore I think in the mental case
issue the the judge would have
discretion not to assign a felony and
and take the proper action in sentencing
do you agree with that that's how I
yes present appr you good any question
I'm thinking about jumping up in that
seat
okay everyone set see representative n
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question um I'm concerned a
little bit so I I understand that
knowingly would be um you know that
would speak to the intent but recklessly
to me is a little more concerning um as
far
as you know I I don't know if you could
comment on you know what what would be
an example of recklessly um and also you
I think that you would have to have some
type of standard where first of all they
know that it is a law enforcement
officer an EMS or or something like that
I think if they're not in uniform or not
on duty at that time um but this still
includes people who are not um on duty
at that time or in uniform but it but
the person would need to know that they
are um that that is the profession that
they do um but then also to the idea of
of recklessly and kind of how that might
play
out as far as identification
you would have to know that it was a law
enforcement officer or another Public
Safety official uh for this to apply but
recklessly is a coupable state of mind
just below knowingly so it's purposely
knowingly recklessly negligently so you
would still have to have a significant
state of mind that you're you know what
you're doing is is is reckless or
knowingly and
um again being under the influence of
drugs or alcohol is not considered the
defense for a crime and in the case of
somebody with a m health problem that's
going to be taken into consideration as
representative Newman mentioned um it's
not a mandatory minimum so that's
something that would wash out in trial
and I assume at that point there would
be more concerned with getting that
person assistance than putting them in
jail
thanks I don't see any further questions
thank you representative Manion thank
good morning good morning representative
Mark crew Hillsboro 15 which is
EMS some say I took Jesus off the cross
but that's not true but I've been in it
a long time over 40 years um and yeah
I've been hit a bunch of
times and we always take into the
into account were they in a medical
emergency or were they pissed off
because I ruined their house
representative you're on
TV you were angry or they were
you and they punched me because I ruined
their
high or some other thing like that we
got in the middle of a domestic
recklessly they're mad they throw a
bottle and it hits me in the face yep
that's reckless and they meant to do it
they meant to throw
it their aim was not as good as it
should have been but it got me right and
I have one of my colleagues who will
tell you her story of a deliberate
action and and they been plenty of
actions and when we point it out to the
police they go yeah we're not going to
do anything because nothing will happen
with it so why bother so that's what
this is
for right to give a consequence that if
you hit police Fire
EMS touch them without
permission knowingly recklessly or all
the things there should be a consequence
otherwise we're just open
game and it happens big city small Town
medium
Town it happens everywhere so I believe
this is very important to put some teeth
behind hey don't hit
me right and some people have been beat
up pretty bad if you remember in in the
Elliott some guy has a brain injury and
can't work again because he got beat up
so bad so it happens and there needs to
be a consequence to protect the people
who are coming to help and I would
really appreciate your support in this
and I will take
questions thank you representative
representative
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um I have two
questions the first is um what you were
just saying about the um incidences kind
of being dismissed um and them saying
like it's not going to go anywhere could
you talk more to that like are they
saying like regular assault charges
would not
are just not going to fly as well
because of your uniform essentially the
uniform and that it was a misdemeanor
and way the baill
was they would be out before I completed
saying oh and can I do a followup
followup representative Mar um
Representative no the uh uh other
question was I can't recall uh where the
legis ation went last year do you know
didn't go anywhere it didn't come out of
this committee or or this body uh I
believe it was in the other side of the
wall that okay didn't like it or
something okay that's what I was all I
know is there's still no teeth in me
getting hit okay thank
you representative
lels thanks for taking my question um so
I would assume the current state of the
law it would be an assault charge is
that
correct yep uh and I'm not sure exactly
how that gets charged but it's usually
kind of um under a misdemeanor or a
whatever followup followup do you feel
that because of your uniform and because
of your
status that you are more vulnerable
and more of a
Target in the general public yep sure
sure am I mean uniforms look
similar
um been called a cop and I have to go
hey no EMS if you had a gun pulled on me
and you know had to prove that hey this
is a medical bag not a gun so please
don't shoot
me right so and that happen happens more
often than you
think thank you representative n thank
you madam chair and thanks for taking my
question I think um I I I first of all I
I agree that if we put you in a
situation where you are you know going
into a situation that's going to be um
tense and and things like this might
happen you know we're sending you into
that situation could you give me an
example of what that looks like for
someone who is not in uniform and not at
that time on the
clock not in uniform and if I'm not
working this law doesn't apply to me it
may apply apply to police officers
unless I stop and render help right so
if I'm stopping to help somebody I don't
just walk up and start touching them and
and doing I identify myself I am an EMT
I'm here to help you can I help you
because I need their permission to touch
them right unless they're unconscious
and then implied consent comes in and I
don't need it right so I never touch
anybody without me asking that
identifying myself first
right and before I touch them I'm an
EMT I can help you would you like me to
help you most of the time they say
yes
right yeah I think that would be so so
if I identify
myself and and they know I'm an
EMT and now they choose to punch me in
the face
because they don't like what I'm wearing
I don't
know then yeah this supplies right
because they know who I am and what what
I'm doing for
them okay so where it where it talks
about I'm sorry followup I'm sorry it's
it it's okay
representative it's a follow up trying
to remind myself yes follow up please um
okay so where it talks about um acting
in in the line of duty or um commits an
act against a law enforcement officer
whether or not the officer is on duty
where the purpose was to harm the
officer because of uh his or her pre um
present or previous employment as a law
officer that would be so that's a law
officer that's not an EMT so that
doesn't apply to me that applies to
police officers or a law enforcement
officer or however you look okay because
I'm sure it's in there because bad guys
remember who put them in jail and may
actually come looking for them it has
happened in the past so I'm pretty sure
that's why that's in there so if the
officer walking down the street with his
family going to dinner and the bad guy's
walking this way and says oh I know you
and punches them then that this should
be definitely in place thank
you representative
Muse thank you I'd appreciate if you
could comment on a on a couple of things
um one is uh what is the necessity uh
first of all to arrest somebody without
a warrant and the other is how do you
define let's just do one at a time so we
can make sure we get them all answer for
you okay so the necessity without a
warrant should be asked to the police
office but I know that in certain
um
incidents especially if they didn't
witness it they need to get a warrant so
unless this is written in the law
that they take my word and see my bloody
nose and three other people said that
guy just hit the EMT they don't need to
go get a warrant they can arrest them
right
there I believe that's how it goes I'm
sure the guys in uniform behind me can
clarify that so would it would it be
helpful to the to the committee if we
invited representative Manion to sit at
the same time with representative PR so
we can get our questions answered you
guys all okay with that okay represent
you so I'm going to guess that 92 and a
half% of the time any of these offenses
are going to incur occur in front of a
police officer but that being said we're
allowed to make arrests without a
warrant on any
felony with probable cause so that's
already the
law and I can also answer quickly the
question that uh representative uh lels
had brought up about the current state
of the law
in my
career I had a judge who told us do not
bring any assault against police officer
charges we would just charge him a
simple assault or under the regular
statute because he will not entertain
them because that's our job to be
assaulted so that's why this is needed
snap followup followup representative
Muse so if I understand you correctly if
the penalty was not a felony you would
not be able to make a warrantless arrest
is that correct yes and one more
followup M um
unless unless we witnessed it thank you
and uh I'm curious about uh I I
understand uh you know the reason why
why knowingly or recklessly causing
bodily injury is in a bill like this um
uh I think we all can have a pretty good
idea what that what that would be what
I'm having what I'm struggling with a
little bit is uh unprivileged physical
contact because the way the bill is is
actually written it seems like you know
on the one one hand you'll get charged
if you bash somebody in the in the nose
and break their nose and they get a
bloody nose and you injure somebody on
the other hand unprivileged physical
contact could be anything from
inadvertently brushing against somebody
a push some you know um and uh it just
seems I'm just curious why it why it's
in there at the same level as what seems
like a pretty serious assault yes so
that's in the second degree assault
level so the penalty is less that's to
be felony um the goal there was just to
prevent assaulting police officers um I
understand the concern there where
generally speaking with the general
public any kind of unprivileged physical
contact the definition would mean any
kind of touching whatsoever um so it's
possible we can clarify that section of
it or remove it but the goal is to
prevent any assaults so you I mean you
could push an officer punch him and not
cause bodily injury should that be I
mean should that be okay should that be
a violation or misdemeanor that's why we
you so if this helps anybody um
clarifying this would also be a question
so
I'm I I serve on a board for the for the
county level for for juveniles that
found themselves to be arrested and
there had been a situation where
um
somebody it was a domestic violent
situation but it actually involved
teenagers okay and when the officers
came
the the the one youth was very concerned
because she felt as if she was getting
in trouble when she was the one that
called for
help and where the confusion was is she
she wasn't being in trouble but the
officers were trying to remove her from
the situation but she was very very
erratic she was just the situation was
bad and unfortunately for her and for
the officer she bit him and she did draw
blood was pretty
bad but they didn't BR the charges that
she had was because it continued after
they stopped it right like like you're
biting us right so there was a my
understanding was that was a pretty
clear line of the officers actually
trying to help her with the distress
that she clearly had and then there's
also this line of okay now you're just
you're just angry and taking it out on
us so in that
situation how is that handled or like
what is the the professional line where
an officer is clearly able to see this
person is under
distress they're not necessarily mad at
me they're just mad at the situation and
I happen to be in the way is there a
line there or is it
a matter of opinion where
professionalism comes into
play yeah so that's going to depend on a
lot of things the officers involved um
I'm not going to speak for all of them
it's also going to depend situation to
situation so I mean a situation like
that you obviously you're there
initially um
to either arrest her Tak her custody get
her help whatever your cause is but
there does reach a point where you can
sense that she's now turning on you
because you've got your hands on her and
it's not about the situation that
brought you there so that would be
probably where the line is where you you
give them a warning and a second warning
and they're still coming after you at
that point where you would draw that
line and in that case if she's a
juvenile this doesn't change the
juvenile laws so she would still be
charged or not charged based on that but
so it doesn't change anything else other
than the penalty for this offense so
okay yeah thank you thank you for that
explanation I think that might be
helpful to people that have some
questions oh who else anybody else good
represent what you
name so yeah please follow a pink card
you can go testify sure so I'll add a
little bit more because I know like in
the police
World um I actually have a ball spot on
the top of my head thanks for sharing
and
and and it came from a little old lady
who was in a nursing home trashed the
whole day room
and we were trying to get her out and
she needed shoes on so as I bent over to
help her with her shoes she grabbed on
and ripped it
out the thought of charging her never
even came across my mind because she was
obviously in a crisis and and was
just going with it so uh we take that
into account you know we're not here to
try and get everybody arrested arrested
that touches us is for the ones that do
it
deliberately knowingly or or whatever so
yeah so in that case if it was a
16-year-old male football player who was
6 foot2 and 280 PBS you might not give
him as much leeway as you would say you
know a 14-year-old 90 PB person who's
flailing and stuff like that a bite
that's different it's no matter who it's
coming from but uh yeah so it depends on
all those factors okay thank you all
right oh represent so close so close
gentlemen representative n one more
question I promise sure um I do a lot of
work in um trauma informed care and
stuff like that and I think that a lot
of the situations that we're describing
it reminds me very much of you know to
to a um an extreme degree uh but
situations that might arise because of
someone's trauma do you guys go through
training trauma informed training as
police officers and
EMS yeah we do quite a bit yeah either
from the academy or from uh private
agencies that would come in and do
training yes we do okay thank you y
representative pette just so you know I
generally would would call any
Representatives first um but we've had
PE people that obviously are trying to
testify and they might be able to clear
up some of the questions that were asked
okay Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire the national Alli on
mental illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I am here today to speak in opposition
to House Bill 59 but not you know
completely in opposition to it just to
you know ask the committee to kind of
look at it slow it down and and see you
know how The Advocates can work with the
First Responders to get some language
that will work for everybody Nami New
Hampshire firmly believes in and
supports the critical services that
First Responders provide for the safety
and well-being of our
communities oftentimes individuals in
Mental Health crisis find themselves
interacting with First Responders on
some of the worst days of their
lives we find that First Responders are
an important element of the Mental
Health crisis response and their safety
and well-being must be crucially
protected however we have significant
concerns that house bill 59 as
introduced will significantly and
punitively impact individuals with
mental health Crisis and Believe that
people in crisis deserve treatment in
support not to be arrested jailed or
facing disproportionate
penalties as you've heard under the
current law police cannot arrest a
person for a misdemeanor offense unless
it's committed in front of the officer
or if there's certain conditions that
are
met Senate Bill 59 would instead provide
that warrantless
arrests um for any individual accused of
assault of a first responder by raising
it to a felony level and that's what
makes it um makes them able to arrest
without the warrant is because um it
raises um simple assault to a uh felony
level in this uh bill
as mentioned earlier folks with mental
illness often interact with First
Responders on the worst days of their
lives and as such their actions may be
Reckless or unpredictable and may result
in bodily injury or more importantly the
unprivileged contact that you heard
about
um therefore we expect this bill would
cause more individuals with a mental
illness to often face the higher
penalties established in the bill bill
due to their frequent interactions with
First
Responders this bill would also make
obtaining release on bail more difficult
resulting in more folks with active
mental illness residing in jails around
the
state while the K committee May
determine that there is a need to
provide increased protections for First
Responders there must also be a balance
of protecting the rights and the
freedoms of individuals with mental
illness and just by way of background
from 2021 to 2023 Nami New Hampshire was
involved in a stakeholder group
discussing a similar issue that's the
subject matter of this bill when it came
to health care
workers as a part of that effort in 2021
there was a committee to study workplace
safety and health care
settings um during the two years that it
met the legislative committee worked
with stakeholders including Nami New
Hampshire to come to a resolution that
prioritize the safety of healthcare
workers while also addressing the
concerns of mental health and the
Disability
Advocates this resulted in language that
passed in Senate Bill 58 from
2023 and as we can learn from that
process changes in the law that may
disproportionately affect the rights of
an already vulnerable population should
use time and careful consideration to
make sure that an axe isn't being used
when a scalpel could do
it is Paramount that people in
psychiatric crisis continue to have the
due process protections afforded to them
under the law and if house bill of 59
passes as is we expect that more people
in a mental health crisis would face
higher level charges and language in
county jails which would only serve to
exacerbate their crisis for those
reasons Nami New Hampshire is in
opposition to this bill as I said as it
is drafted and while I was back there
I'm not I am an attorney but I've never
on criminal law but while I was back
there I did look up the definition of
recklessly which is consciously
disregarding a substantial risk of harm
to others and when someone's in a
psychiatric crisis they may know that
flailing their arms around and touching
somebody is they're they're knowingly
doing that um they're knowingly flailing
their arms and I would you know as I
said I don't do criminal law but I would
be seriously you know concerned about
um the uh the standard that's in here um
you know if it was purposefully um that
might be different but we're really
concerned about the standard that's in
here because someone's just flailing
their arms around in a psychiatric
crisis and happens to hit but not injure
a first responder they could end up with
a felony on the record which would
seriously impact their ability to get
employment and to get housing and so we
just urge the committee just to slow
this down a little bit and allow The
Advocates to maybe work with the first
responder of community to come with a
come come to a resolution that everybody
can live with thank
you thank you Miss Stevens um have you
have you reached out to the sponsor of
the bill to to have a conversation with
them about the concerns or the changes
that you would like to see in there I
didn't reach out to the sponsor my first
um effort was to reach out to um the the
person who represents the police Chiefs
and was not able to connect with with
her in the time frame of when this bill
was being heard and could you share
maybe some of the so you had said um not
to take an axe when maybe a scalpel
would do so
it it seems from from the language in
the bill that there that there is a
scalpel now that is that is used um what
you would like to see I guess I should
sentence I'm just looking at it now I I
mean I think like I said the standard
that's being um identified in the
bill is concerning to
us
um bless
you I've got the wrong bill in front of
me here it is um the recklessly um
standard is concerning um um this one's
and then the unprivileged physical
contact is concerning because that is
simply you know touching
somebody without any um harm whatsoever
so those are some of the concerns and
also raising this to the felony level is
concerning you know it would be I think
we would rather work with the First
Responders within the warrantless arrest
statute itself to try to come up with a
car out in the warrantless arrest
statute that would allow for a
warrantless arrest without being a
felony so those are some of our concerns
that we would like to you know talk and
possible okay thank
you representative
sheer um again in the interest of uh
full disclosure uh Miss Stevens has The
Misfortune of Being a former student of
H she was a a teaching assistant so um
would it be fair to say that if the
words were instead of being knowingly or
recklessly it was purposely that would
be uh uh of that would address a lot of
the circumstances if not all the
circumstances yes um purposely is a much
higher standard to reach and somebody
just flailing their arms around in a um
psychiatric crisis um wouldn't
necessarily it wouldn't be the standard
you know they wouldn't reach the level
of purposefully but again they would
potentially re reach the level of
recklessly so that is the concern follow
up followup um and it's fair to say that
this bill also addresses another
category of people that uh in my
experience being a police commissioner
the police deal with in a relatively
regular basis are those elderly people
who are suffering from uh Dementia or or
uh whatever the whatever the particular
term is and is not fully conscious of
what's going on around me around them PR
in slip
um this addresses that group too and the
concern is the same uh that recklessly
is too low a standard yes and I know
that um my colleague um miss Karen
Rosenberg will be uh discussing um
Alzheimer's as a concern but yes that is
is one of the one of the groups that
also would be um caught up in this um
that we could end up with folks with
dementia in the county jail um and not
even knowing where they're at and what
the what's going on which would be a
huge concern for for them last
followup um are you familiar with the
kinds of services that would be
available to a person suffering from a
mental illness or in from Alzheimer's or
dementia uh while they're being held
pre-trial at a at a jail it's my
understanding that there aren't really
any services that are offered pre-trial
thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank you for letting me speak um
Kathleen pockette uh from Manchester and
this bill is important to me and my
family um because my I have two
daughters I was an EMS myself and I have
two daughters uh one's an EMT one's a
paramedic um and my husband has been a
paramedic for 38 years um and all three
of them have had have been injured or
have been hurt um so I'm hoping I have
some personal experience which may help
um representative Muse's question about
touching and also representative n's
question about being in plain clothes um
as far as a touching um one of my
daughters she was actually 19 years old
and she was in the back of an ambulance
with a patient and she and so her driver
so she's alone and her driver was
driving them to the hospital and um the
person that was driving had no idea that
the pass in the back the patient had my
daughter by the
throat um she wasn't
injured but it was intended to cause an
injury it was intended to seriously
injure her so thankfully somebody was
able to stop the ambulance get out of
the ambulance and intervene before she
got an injury so I think that's why that
touching um is very important because
she wasn't hurt thank God but that
physical touching was intended to injure
her um and as far as the um out of
uniform um like I said my husband uh has
worked for 38 years in EMS and he does
not work in the state intentionally um
because he's had episodes in the past
where he's had patients that he's ran
into in the grocery store um and not
everybody you know loves
EMS because either they don't take them
where they want or you know like uh
representative pu said you know you're
you're ruining their high as as they see
but you know you've just saved their
lives um and they're not happy so he's
actually had several incidentes with
people recognizing him out of
uniform um so he therefore for safety
his own safety he chooses to work out of
recognized thank you um and thank you
for taking my question um I know you
know one thing that I'm very familiar
with is I just want to talk about kind
of this idea of like ruining somebody's
high right um and kind of drill down on
what that looks like because I do know
that when people are resuscitated with
nooon sometimes um when they uh wake up
from that essentially when they come
back um they are flailing they are they
don't know what's happening they're very
very disoriented and so I just want to
kind of establish what that exactly what
that looks like cuz I can imagine that
being possibly interpreted by
some it can be but there's sort of a
little bit of a timeline cuz that's
something that I had experienced myself
um and you know somebody comes out and
they're flailing and they're mad but
usually several moments later they
realize that you know they're now sober
and it's usually upon that that they you
know at times not everyone obviously not
every single time and not everyone but
that is the time when they realized oh
you know I was high and now I'm not and
it's your fault so you know that initial
sort of waking up there can be flailing
in that but then there's that moment of
realization that comes a little bit
after okay and that's only that's only
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm here
representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties which is the
trade Association for all your elected
and appointed officials uh the
association is in support of this bill
but we would like to make one minor
suggestion that you add correctional
officers to this list while correctional
officers are considered law enforcement
officers in the past if they have not
been specifically listed they are not
included um certainly the um second half
of the bill uh counties are certainly
set up under the magistrate program to
handle the uh bail via judge or
magistrate so that would not be an issue
for counties certainly we do not want
people languishing in the County
Correctional Facility Who are in mental
Health crisis but uh we feel that there
are procedures in place to handle that
bail situation if someone were to come
in um and as far as the felony that is a
policy decision is not a position that
the association is taking at this time
but I'm happy to answer any questions
have representative n yeah I didn't talk
at all yesterday so I'm just up you're
excuse me thank you for taking my
question what uh representative sherff
said about pre-trial Services really
kind of struck a chord with me and I was
wondering if you might be able to speak
to what exactly that would look like and
being able to identify whether it was
someone who was in a mental health
crisis in which case we wouldn't want
them to to be held in that situation
sure thank you for that question that's
not a decision for County Corrections
that would be a decision for the judge
or the magistrate who is seeing them
can I follow up real quick um because my
intention is not to say it's what I'm
really trying to ask is kind of what
that what that looks like if someone
does and that's not something that you
feel comfortable speaking
to thank you for the question I believe
I can answer your question if I don't
get it right try again so if someone
comes in last year this committee did
extraordinary work around House Bill 318
and set up the uh 13 crimes that are
listed that include first degree in
assault and second degree assault for
someone who would not see a bail
commissioner they would see either a
judge or a magistrate we've worked very
closely with the courts to set up those
procedures so if you come in during the
week um normal no normal hours within 24
hours you have to see a judge if you are
coming in on the weekends you have to
see the magistrate because obviously the
judges are not in their office um and we
have worked out a essentially a schedule
with the courts for every County to have
a specific time where if they have
someone who falls under those
jurisdictions to set up a call so that
they can have their review done within
the time period that you all laid out in
318 last year um Counties have set up uh
virtual uh hearings so that way we don't
have to physically bring people to the
courts um we can do it over Zoom or some
other telephonic Communications does
that answer your question yeah it does
it anybody else we all set thank you
very
much representative PR I I realized you
were telling me you could answer that
question but if you could maybe after
we're all done just like address that so
we can let the people testify thank
good morning my name is Karen Rosenberg
I am the policy director at the
disability rights Center which is our
state's protection and advocacy system
for people with disabilities and I'm
here to testify in opposition to this
bill on behalf of the disability rights
Center I mean first I need to say that
um someone said not everyone loves EMS
providers I love them I understand their
jobs are so tough and and that they go
into situations intending to help people
save people's lives and and are entering
sometimes situations that end up being
harmful to them and that is terrible so
in no way um I mean I I I just I can't
imagine what that's like for them but
what I'm concerned about is that this
bill if it passes as written is going to
have an unintentional really negative
horrible consequence on people who
experience various kinds of disabilities
as you heard from Holly Stevens from
Nami you know there's concerns about
people who are facing an emotional
behavioral mental health crisis and are
just hearing voices or having a a break
really with reality and are very very
agitated but I'm also concerned about
people who are experiencing intellectual
or developmental disabilities people
with acquired brain injuries people like
my dad who suffered from Alzheimer's and
this is very emotional for me
because my father who was the sweetest
person I mean we never I I'm older right
my friends they did something wrong they
get a little whack I got a lecture okay
I never he never raised a hand but when
he was in his 80s and his mind was
getting erased by this terrible disease
he became aggressive and sometimes like
would you know agitated and sometimes
even violent he wandered a lot and even
though he was older um he managed to
elude my mother um and sometimes would
just disappear when she was trying to do
something like you know run into the
library to you know give her you know
return a book or whatever and that would
be it you know he also had health
physical health issues um he had heart
disease and so I can just totally
Envision the time where I mean there
were times when she would call the
police or someone for help and if
someone approached my dad even when he
was in a care facility when he didn't
expect them um and they were trying to
help him it might be with something that
had to do with taking care of like
wiping off his face if there was
something on it anything he would reach
out grab them he bruised my mom who
tried to like help him to take some
medications at one point but this was
his disease right this isn't something
that you'd want to see him hauled into
court or to jail about and you know and
the idea that oh sure he'll get before a
magistrate or a judge within 24 to 36
hours would I mean the harm that would
be done for him being out of his
environment and what and for what
purpose when I think about what is the
purpose you know there there are various
purposes of our criminal law right one
is to punish people who do objectively
bad things right they cause physical
harm they do something you know breaks
our our civil code um it's also a
deterrent right I don't think that this
kind of legislation is going to prevent
these kinds of unintentional acts from
happening and sometimes there could be
harm involved so what this does is it
takes a misdemeanor where which you know
someone you know which includes
unprivileged physical conduct without
harm but also it could include the kind
of injury that my father caused when he
would you know try to get someone away
from him and cause a bruise that would
be bodily injury
and it raises that to a felony it means
that someone in that position it's right
now if that happened right now
today that would be a misdemeanor
someone could go and get an arrest
warrant and have my dad arrested but in
the meantime he would be transported to
whatever it is and needs to get his care
and he'd get his care and then if if an
arrest warrant issued then that happened
and he'd have to deal with it it's not
like there's no consequences possible
but then all these issues around
competency could be raised bed um you
know I'm using my dad as an example but
you can see it happening with someone
with a developmental disability a brain
injury someone who doesn't have the
executive functioning skills intact to
know what's going on now I appreciate I
have to say it was heartwarming to hear
representative PR's testimony about the
unfortunate loss of a hair which is
terrible and I'm sure that really hurt a
lot and it was really heartwarming to
hear that he had the that he was kind
and understood where this was coming
from and made a decision that this was
not something to be prosecuted but but
we would have this on our books and not
everyone not every person who's a first
responder even though I said I love
First Responders but I don't know that
100% of them are as caring and would
take that kind of rational just Humane
approach to a situation that results in
some pain and an injury like loss of
hair or something else so for those
reasons I think this is really
problematic overly broad I think it's
not going to prevent injuries to our
First Responders there may be other ways
to prevent injuries to First Responders
I don't know exactly what some of them
are I think that it's just it it is a
problem that we ought to study and try
to make more resources available to
those folks because they are trying to
you know they they they are like our
Angels right um but I feel that the the
consequences of of this are really dire
so for all those reasons we would oppose
the legislation this bill as as drafted
questions representative Murphy thank
you madam chair um I uh empathize with
your situation I too had a a parent with
Alzheimer's who behaved much the way you
you do and I also have a son with a
traumatic brain injury who has minimal
executive functioning skills uh both of
which would concern me in this issue as
a healthc care provider a former nurse I
too recognize that we need to be able to
protect those people who are trying to
to try to help our our patients um I'm
not sure but I I believe that I was on
the subcommittee for that um prior Bill
about health uh which addressed pretty
much the same situation but with a
different population so we were
healthare providers sp58 and there was a
St there was a work for um Healthcare
Workforce Coalition that DRC played a
role in also that that was what I was my
question was were you part of that and
did you have suggestions as to how we
might make this better so that we
achieve the protection that we need for
EMS but also protect the vulnerable
populations that that they may be that
they are facing every day right so my my
predecessor I've been in this role this
is my fourth legislative session my
predecessor Mike Skiby who was our
policy director before me was involved
in that um directly and then I was
involved um more recently in um sort of
honing the language that resulted in s
sp58 which ultimately passed so I would
welcome the opportunity to work with
folks on trying to address this issue um
it did take some time as I understand it
what one of the things that the um
Healthcare Workforce safety commission
did was they also looked to collect data
on on this and I think that would really
important to understand um you know how
often this happens who are the folks
assaulting um our First Responders and
um what what training is there what are
what are the factors leading up to this
I think there's information that would
be really helpful to gain um if there
was some study further study done in
addition to looking at what you're
talking about representative Murray and
how it is that Murphy sorry how it is
that we could um carve out situations
where um we're not you know punishing
people whose behavior is really directly
related to having a disability but not
um allowing folks to you know like ought
you know who who have that men Rea who
have that purposeful intent and you know
to harm someone who's there to help them
um that that might be something to
really work on but I don't know that I
that's not an answer that I can just
quickly come up with um there are also
already there's in our criminal code as
I understand it there is um a specific
provision um that protects Corrections
Officers from assaults against well it
doesn't protect them it creates an
additional felony when prisoners um
assault and harm a corrections officer
so that does exist already I think I
pulled it out it's um six it's RSA 642
colon 9 so um and if they if someone is
a prisoner and they commit an assault um
as defined under 631 which is the um RSA
you're looking at amending now um it
would be considered a class B felony and
then the sentence would run concurrently
not concurrently what is it
consecutively sorry um with the sentence
that the person's already serving so
there are protections there and um I
couldn't help myself but representative
L there is LEL there is a statute ready
that um adds it to be that creates a um
crime it may also be a felony hold on
for
um for assaults against someone who's
like in the general
court or elected
official no um yeah I G to find it for
you because I did oh here it is 631
colon 4-a harmer threats to certain
government officials so um that that
does create an additional um class a
felony
representative
Shar thank you madam Pier
um what language would you recommend to
sort this out I I I like I said I don't
think I can come up with that off the
top of my head I'd really want to think
about it I think it's complicated um
because one thing I worry about is how
is someone who is an um like an EMS
going to know that the person they are
are being FL at by has one of these
conditions so I I just I I don't I don't
know the answer right now I think we can
think about I think put a put some
brains together we can come up with
something well me rep followup I do
believe that they are very much trained
on that as a matter of fact um certainly
to recognize to recognize those and if
they're with a family member that would
certainly be a tell when they when
they're letting you know that but follow
up yeah I and in that pain Madam chair U
I'm aware you know uh the Portsmouth
Police Department gets a lot of training
uh the officers get a lot of training on
managing those who are in Mental Health
crisis uh we um and we we Avail
ourselves of the mobile crisis units um
but um you know what about language that
carves out of this statute a certain
population do you think that's a good
way to approach this or I'm just getting
your general thoughts
I mean it might be I'm also thinking
about like people who are deaf and heart
of hearing who might respond in a way
that's unexpected I mean I mean there
may be other kinds of disabilities
perhaps there I don't want to say no I
think I'd like to work on it there may
be a way to do this um but I think it
would require some thought and I do know
I am aware that there's a lot of
training um for police officers through
the police academy I don't know how much
training there is available for EMS
workers or EMTs if it's as robust and if
there's um you know what the the bread
of and depth of training is in terms of
trauma informed approaches and um
deescalation and those which is really
important when you're approaching
someone as well so that would be
something to consider uh last for
fortunately we have uh several um
firemen EMT and police officers on this
committee that could tell us that
whenever we uh go into our executive
session um just so everybody knows we
are coming up to um pretty much an hour
we still have three more people that
would like to testify so if we could
make sure we just really kind of answer
our answer the questions at hand um
representative Muse did you have a
question I thought I saw your hand up
you're all set okay all right are we
representative
Newman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I have a
concern about the on the last page of
the bill on p on page one it talks about
the extended term of imprisonment under
uh
6516 G1 to read as follows and then I
don't see I'm I'm having to um that that
that was I'm sorry that was a different
issue can I can I correct my question
yes I'll get to that um I won't I'll
figure that other one out later on um
there is a term in on the page one line
14 that talks about
597 uh a defendant is is
dangerous um under RSA and that's
that and and it it references paragraph
3 A1 and I don't know if you have
anything in your information when you
studied it and for the for the sponsors
it's just that I can't find it anywhere
and I've searched all over the computer
to just find this the citation that's
there so we may need help with that
later thank you madam chair so I have
never practiced criminal law okay um I
did look at this RSA and so I will tell
you what my quick understanding is but I
suggest that you speak with someone ask
this question of someone who has as I
understand it what this would do is
create a presumption of dangerousness
which is a factor that a court would
look into in terms of determining
whether to um allow the person to be
discharged on personal recognizance or
bail as opposed to having to wait at the
County Corrections Facility to have
before they have their
hearing but that's but like I said
qualify that thank you very much
okay right thank you very much thank you
Lauren
Barry hello everyone uh my name is
Lauren Barry I'm a certified firefighter
Advanced CMT in the state of New
Hampshire bear with me I'm really
nervous because I am not a public
speaker uh to give you a little
background on myself I have practiced
medicine
since I was 18 years old I'm now 35 I've
practiced in places in the state of New
Hampshire uh more so in eping F eing New
Hampshire and Manchester New Hampshire
both different different
demographics uh I now currently work in
Somerville Mass ever Chelsea all very
different demographics I've worked in uh
New York with FDNY and Harlem Queens
I've worked on the border of Mexico and
very poverty-driven places La Hoya
Brownsville New Jersey nework Jersey
City so to say that I have a diverse
background in different demographics and
the different types of patients you can
encounter on a 9911 call would be an
understatement uh me personally I've
been assaulted and uh verbally
physically more times than I can count
in this career as well as my
co-workers um I personally two years ago
was assaulted to the point where I
required an ER evaluation after the call
I was kicked in the face in the chest
multiple times from a patient
that made an a an active decision to
drink that
evening and through that drinking was
angry that that particular patient had
to go to the hospital and while taking
that patient out of the ambulance I was
in a vulnerable position doing my job in
front of an officer I was kicked in the
face in the chest it was on camera that
patient fa a Mis meanor charge and was
let off with Rehabilitation of
rehab that should say
something that people that advocate for
mental health patients I'm now mental
health patient where's my
advocacy at what point does my life
matter for somebody to protect me all
everyone I invite you to come work with
us for shift I invite you to come see
the discretion that we have with every
individual patient that struggles I
invite you to come see how much training
we have to decipher whether the patient
has has a mental health crisis whether
they have a brain injury whether they
have dementia there's a lot of signs
there's an abundance of training that we
go through we are given a role in this
uniform that we are allowed to make
decisions we are licensed to a level
of standing protocols that we're
allowed because we're trusted with these
decisions we're trusted to save your
loved ones lives with medication and
decisions critically thinking and
chaos so to think that we don't deal
with discretion and take the time to
have an understanding of if the
patient's having a mental health crisis
versus intently making a decision with
intent to
injure is slightly no offense
disrespectful I take this job so
seriously most would say I put it before
myself more days than not in fact I'm
should be at work right now I'm missing
pay to be here because that's how
important this is to me when I found out
that this state didn't have a felony
charge for somebody that could kick me
in the face in the chest and not get
penalized for
it Choice words were made let's just say
that I think uh I can't speak for the
sponsors of this bill but I think the
point is uh being missed here that we're
not just going to charge every single
person that raises a hand to us this
bill was meant and created with a
purpose to have protection and to uphold
a standard that will'll not be tolerated
that we will be assaulted because
someone got angry when you were taught
as a child that you had big emotions
were you penalized and punished for
hitting your your classmates your
siblings why is it okay to hit somebody
in uniform that's called to help you I
didn't sign on for a job that the years
I've been doing this I say I can't tell
you how many new hires and probies oh
violence is just part of the job why is
that an acceptable thing why is why am I
okay with accepting that you wouldn't
accept it in your
relationships why is it okay for me to
accept it in a uniform because someone
called 911 and I responded the amount of
times I've been assaulted and never once
sought to seek charges on that person
whether it was because someone told me
they wouldn't go anywhere the person
wouldn't show up for court that it was a
waste of time when this happened the
prosecutor called me and said yeah
nothing's really going to happen she's
going to go to rehab she admitted that
she has a problem with
drinking okay so in the future when I
get in trouble I can just say I have a
problem with drinking that gets me out
of
time the amount of training that we go
through the amount of extra effort we go
to in each call the amount of tact that
we have with each patient the amount of
times that I have called someone sir
after they've called me a derogatory
name please understand that we love your
loved ones we wouldn't if we didn't do
this job because we don't get paid I
can't tell you how many people in
uniform have multiple jobs because we
don't make a wage that really supports
cost of living in these days and that's
a whole different issue but I'm just
saying most people that wear this uni
form it's because they have a passion
for it they have a passion for taking
the extra last night I stayed 25 minutes
past my shift because an elderly woman
with dementia who was anxious couldn't
find her glasses and she was vicious
gosh was she vicious her issue was she
couldn't find her blue eyeglasses and I
wouldn't leave until I found the blue
eyeglasses was that my job no but did it
settle her for the night yes
yes I'm just trying to say I had this
whole thing written out I was going to
be so tactful and professional and I
realized I'm just going to be myself
I've been shot at in this career I've
been held captive in
apartments I have been spit at kicked
punched more times you know the person
that's having the Mental Health crisis
you take the extra time to still talk
calmly to them the person with a
disability you take the time to talk
quiet
to take time with them to get down low
on their level the person with an
elderly issue that's digging their nails
into your arm you ask nicely ma'am can
you please release my arm you don't dig
your nails back into her arm because
she's hurting you did I swing back on
the person that hit me no because I'm a
professional this bill wasn't put in
place so that we can just carelessly
throw felonies at people that raise
their arms or their feet it's with a
purpose and with intent you make a
decision every single day of your life
if you chose to get up today and go
drink from that drinking and what occurs
in that drinking was your choice if you
chose to get up in day to do to do drugs
that's your choice I understand people
in mental health issues I have my own
now from this
job I understand people that have
traumatic brain injuries I have the
utmost respect for them that must be
really difficult to live like that every
day people with dementia it can happen
at a really young age you could be 45
years old with early dementia you can't
just assume because they're young that
they don't have
dementia I ask you to be a little more
informed in what we do with uniform and
please at any point in time if any of
you would like to come do the job with
us for a few hours feel free I would
gladly take you
around this bill was just meant to
protect us in the situations like mine
where I took a boot a work boot to the
face in the
chest and nobody was held accountable
for it
thank you Miss Barry I just one quick
question where were the blue
glasses under the computer naturally
AC ad right chair committee members
thank you for your time I appreciate
that this hearing has run over time so I
will try to fly through this um and if
you all have questions I appreciate that
but I also respect that you all have
more hearings so um I believe there are
of course very good intentions behind
supporting the concept of this bill but
I urge that you pause and not move
forward at this time I asked the
committee to pump the brakes on going
down the path of adding further enhanced
penalties based on Career or profession
especially when we already have extended
terms of imprisonment in our laws when a
victim is an emergency
responder if those aren't being used
that's a different
conversation we need to acknowledge that
if a statute is not working creating
additional statute language is not
really solving the things that are being
testified to
today um the opportunity to coorse
people with the threat of very long life
destroying sentences creates an
off-putting power Dynamic that can lead
to abuse I think that's really important
when we've seen these bills in other
states it's important to highlight again
New Hampshire ER carves out enhan
penalties for the exact emergency
responders listed listed in HB 59 but in
a different way if you want a special
place in our laws for emergency
responders we have that we do
acknowledge and value that they go into
very dangerous places and deal with very
intense situations on a routine
basis however going much further than
what we already have in statute and
adding specific careers directly into
the assault statute itself is all deeply
concerning HB 59 is changing a lot about
our criminal law statutes changing the
level of offenses changing the person's
rights pre-trial changing the years of
incarceration
and changing the standard and harm
required for these new
felonies for example second degree
assault a felony facing up to seven
years in prison would be changed to just
any bodily injury that would include a
scratch while the folks who testify
today I understand would not potentially
seek charges there the criminal legal
system is very complex and individual
situations get very heightened very
quickly and we do not need these really
overwhelming types of charges lingering
over people's
heads it even has only unprivileged
physical
contact that's no injury required for a
felony assault where you could get up to
seven
years something I'll discuss later is
the importance of when it comes to plea
bargaining what actually happens when
you're facing these types of really
intense prison sentences folks are not
going to trial that rarely happens
except for in Law and Order we're
talking about negotiations and the power
dynamics that come into
play currently in New Hampshire if
someone knowingly recklessly or
purposely assaults a police officer or
other emergency responders it is already
a felony that with enhanced penalties
may receive 10 to 30 years in prison if
someone commits simple assault a
misdemeanor against a police officer it
may be enhanced to F two to 5 years in
sentences even without enhancements I
want to flag that our assault statutes
are severe in and of itself for any
person something that I think should
really be considered more than maybe
some of my other points is that this is
not a deterrent and I believe that a lot
of times when we are passing criminal
laws we Aspire for them to be
deterrence and that in this case
especially does not work people who are
responding to emergency situations are
often dealing with as discussed here
people who are in their worst moments
their worst marital moment possibly
having a mer uh a mental health crisis
under the influence dealing with medical
issues conditions disabilities
PTSD there's a heightened stress anxiety
and panic in this situation despite best
efforts no one is going to remember if
they ever knew the difference in prison
they may not even understand fully
what's happening where they are they're
panicking maybe not even thinking what
they're doing is assault deterrent is
not happening in this specific case
someone who's willing to knowingly and
truly assault an officer or an EMT is
not going to stop and calmly think
through the sentencing guidelines
associated with that
either we do not want everyone in these
heightened States or under these
circumstances criminalized to such a
severe
degree we need to fully consider will
this be a tool to force plea bargaining
or other problematic outcomes with many
vulnerable
defendants we are talking about
automatic felonies for a host of wildly
different types of community members
with different reasons for their
actions we are also talking about a
situation where police or EMT are now
walking away with potential ually no
injuries or a minor scratch and the
other person is now facing years in
prisons and the dynamic that that then
creates I ask the committee to take time
to discuss whether this will be a
deterrent or if it may be more along the
lines of seeking increased retribution
with very long and expensive prison
sentences though I very much appreciate
the good intentions here we have real
concerns of police overusing the charge
especially in cases where they fear the
person will claim police brutality we
have seen this in other states with
similar
laws assaulting police and emergency
responders is of course never okay no
one here disagrees with that but that
does not mean that we need to push
incredibly long incredibly long prison
sentences where the laws are already in
place for both the police and
prosecutors to handle if someone
assaults one of their own if they're not
handling that that's a different
conversation f colonization in this
manner increases the chances that people
will be forced into plea bargaining with
the threat of felony
charges also lastly I would just like to
add who gets added next to our assault
statutes as we have seen in many other
states once a criminal statutes are
expand expanded to include specific
occupations or professions the push will
continue to add more professions I've
seen bills for bouncers there there's a
host this is a large thing I think we
should pause and discuss um I don't
think we want to go down this path of
ranking different professionals to a
higher class directly in our criminal
laws in some there's good reason to
reconsider HB 59 mass incarceration has
been and continues to be fueled by ever
increasing long sentences longer
sentences have not been shown to be a
significant deterrent and people
incarcerated will only consider to get
older and older in our prison system
with long
sentences if the goal is to support
emergency responders let's use tax
resources that would be wasted on
further prison sentences on increasing
emergency response times more robust
rural ambulance services and other much
needed supports in our community thank
you for your time I know it's been a
long
hearing thank
you yeah representative
Murray thank you madam chair thank you
for uh taking my question um I wasn't
sure if you said the RSA where the
extended prison term already exists do
you have that on hand I do I don't have
all my notes but I believe it's
RSA 651 colon 6 okay thank
you thank you very much thank
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Elizabeth Sergeant
I work for she Infinity Capital group
here in conquered and I'm here today
representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police I'm just
going to make a couple of statements I
know it's been a long hearing um we are
in support of this bill um and I um just
want to say knowingly or recklessly
causes serious bodily injury we think
this is a serious bill um and I will
apologize to Holly she did reach out to
me absolutely we are monitoring every
bill in your committee so every night
the night before we're working through
the next day so we are more than happy
to sit down with um the stakeholders in
this room um I've spoken to the sponsor
we're happy to work in a subcommittee um
to flesh out some of the issues that
were raised um and the only other thing
I did want to say we did look at Senate
Bill 78 we think that is a specific
Health Care setting so we think that is
not the same as this bill um and I guess
I just wanted to say in representing law
enforcement these last few years I think
they do take the totality of the
circumstances into consideration and I
think they're very much aware of um the
um public that they are protecting and I
think that they um try to do their very
best and I uh may not be able to answer
any technical questions um but I be
happy to uh send those questions back to
my client I'm not sure why she pointed
at me thank you thank you very much Miss
Sergeant I don't see any questions I
would um just like to point out that
there was a lot of
conversation uh amendments change this
change that if uh the sponsors are
interested in doing that I would
encourage you to to reach out to the the
people that um showed interest in
wanting to do that just because of the
large number of bills that the the
committee has that would probably be the
best way to make that happen so thank
you very much so much any questions okay
nobody else is there anybody else
wishing to testify on House Bill 59 that
is not turned in a paint card seeing
none I will close the public hearing um
I I hate to go right into the next
hearing guys but we are about about 20
minutes so we're going to go ahead and
do that if you just need to excuse
yourself I think that would be the best
way to go about that
um I will open the public hearing for
House Bill 109 and invite the prime
sponsor to
introduce his
Bill thank you again Madame chair
members of Criminal Justice and Public
Safety representative Dennis Manion
Rockingham 25 I represent
Salem hopefully this bill is a little
easier um this is this is the second
part of the bill that chairman Roy filed
last year like I said I separated them
into two bills so what this bill does is
add to the false reports to law
enforcement officer statute two
sections one that would make it a
misdemeanor if somebody
knowingly reports to a law enforcement
officer or agency that an officer um has
engaged in
misconduct if if they know that's false
so it's knowingly representing a false
statement of misconduct and the second
part
is in creases it to an a Mis meanor if
they knowingly report uh to an agency by
word action false or baseless
information regarding allegations of
criminal conduct so last year this Bill
had class A MISD demen for both I didn't
think that was appropriate for the
misconduct part of it um but only for
the Criminal part of it and I'll explain
I think it seems pretty obvious but I'll
explain if somebody you arrest someone
and they want to retaliate against you
so they come to the station and say he
was rude to me he called me uh Rachel
slurs he swore at me he violated this
policy that's misconduct the penalty for
that could be some rep you know op
determination from his jaob but it's not
going to be anything where he's going to
be uh charged criminally so that's why I
changed it uh the Criminal part of it
the class they miss me it so um this has
to be knowingly it's pretty high
standard if your intention is to go to
the station or report that this officer
did something he clearly did not do
solely for the purpose of uh retribution
against this officer or if you want to
accuse him of committing type type of a
crime and you know that it's false but
you're doing it for some type of
Retribution then the second part of this
would uh would be affected by it so
those are the two sections of the uh
proposed legislation and I can take any
them representative Newman
thank you Madame
chair could you just this is this is
more of a process question if you if
this were to become law and and uh Roman
number number three would would
happens what is the process somebody
comes in and and does this then what
what would happen how would this be what
would you do if that happened to you and
it would it involved that paragraph So
if somebody came in and made a um
a false allegation that you committed a
crime um and we're we're assuming at
this point it's on duty I've arrested
somebody and they've claimed that I've
committed the crime uh more likely than
that would be on body camera there's a
lot of cameras around today but let's
say it wasn't that would be investigated
by Internal Affairs if they don't have
internal affairs they have a a detective
or a sergeant that would investigate it
or possibly another agency that would
investigate it um and if during that
investigation they found out that this
didn't occur and that the person
they can prove that the person just
falsely made these claims at that point
an investigation would be done against
the other person for making these false
PL under this statute if this would have
passed but the first plot of it would be
making you know investigating the
allegation
first
followup followup
so I'm going to with throw my question
thank you you good I'm good okay
um in this state we have an unfortunate
uh uh problem we read about almost every
week um there are police officers who
are charged with misconduct um we have a
lorry list uh that actually lists a
bunch of them so it does happen I guess
is I guess I I'll just ask you I mean do
you think that having a bill like this
would actually discourage people people
um who've experienced real misconduct
from reporting that
misconduct I don't think so like I said
knowingly is a high standard to reach um
and certainly someone's not going to be
charged and convicted of knowingly just
because we couldn't prove the opposite
so let's say that he made a claim
against somebody and we couldn't prove
the claim true doesn't mean they filed
it intentionally or knowingly and it was
a baseless claim I mean we have charges
or or allegations that are unfounded
that's not going to trigger an
automatic uh charge so we we would we
would have to prove that the person did
it it was ba it was baseless information
it was false and they knew that when
they made the
allegation that's a high
you representative Shear um you said
something that that kind of troubles me
if somebody came into the station and
said officer sure was rude to
me uh and we're about to get body cams
in Portsmouth so they could go look at
the body Cam and see whether that was
true before they started a IIA
investigation Internal
Affairs I'm really troubled by the fact
that the the police department could
then turn around and charge someone with
a misdemeanor just for saying he was
rude when you
know the definition of what counts as
rude really uh is Broad so I'm worried
I'm worried about the scope of how you
describe what kind of reports this
covered so in the case of somebody
claiming that the officer was rude
that's all based on that person's
opinion so if then knowingly coming in
and saying the person was rude to me and
they found out that well we don't think
it rises to the to that level as far as
us taking action against the officer
discipline or whatnot that's not going
to trigger well you said he was rude and
he we don't think he was so you're going
to get charged that's subjective I mean
rudeness so I guess would more apply to
I mean he used a racial slur I mean
Roode is kind of a like I said that's
objective I don't think it's ever going
to come up um that's not what this this
this is for so misconduct would would
would I mean it's it's pretty clear
anything other than that would be
covered I mean rudess is something that
our our opinion of rude is is our
opinion of rude doesn't mean you filed
it
incorrectly and that you're going to get
charged with it because your opinion of
rude is that and that you know that that
officer uh if they determined he wasn't
rude doesn't mean it's going to trigger
trigger this so I understand what you're
saying but I don't think it's enough to
so I know the way that um a lot of times
police get get leads and cases uh from
people who you know who might call in
anonymously and with bone number
tracking systems and things like that
that's a little bit harder to do these
days but in in a case where somebody's
calling in and
Reporting uh some type of misconduct and
the department isn't able to the
department isn't actually able to verify
that or just dismisses it outright um
are are you concerned that that people
won't be reaching out to you in in cases
like that who really should
be no not at all again it's the same
answer I gave you last time with
knowingly is a high burden um
Anonymous uh reports are Anonymous and
if we can't identify the person then
there really no issue with it um this
would this is geared towards somebody
who is intentionally their their purpose
is to make a false claim a false
allegation against a law enforcement
officer in
retaliation and that's their purpose and
it's not someone who's making a claim
that turns out to be unfounded or not
true that's a different scenario the
high thank
you I don't see any more questions thank
you representative thank
you is there anybody here wishing to
testify on House Bill 109 that has not
card if you could just make sure you uh
record good morning ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for uh hearing me
for a moment I'll be uh what I hope will
be mercifully brief my name is Brendan
Davey I'm a major within New Hampshire
State Police I'm the commander of our
operations Bureau and I've been a
certified law enforcement officer for uh
approaching 24 years years now uh I can
say having been a sergeant and a su uh
supervisor of shifts and then uh
Lieutenant as a a unit commander and a
field area Captain prior to my my
current role that um at the same time
that we do and we should take very
seriously every allegation and
misconduct um leveled against any sworn
peace officer in the state of New
Hampshire that it is um and can be a
reasonable concern that some of those
allegations are uh
significant and at the same time
materially false I would only submit uh
for the sake of the sponsor of the bill
um and for your consideration as well
that misconduct within the state of New
Hampshire in terms of uh law enforcement
10519 uh and that statute specifically
sites I want to say six or seven
particular
offenses um with specificity that count
as misconduct and perhaps uh if this
statute were to point specifically to
that one and say it's it's not a matter
of rudeness it's not a matter of I felt
that he was
heavy-handed um or or she you know I
didn't like the way that she handled me
on this car stop which are matters of
professionalism and should still be
investigated and should still be dealt
with because we do need to be
professional whereas what we're talking
about is a violation of a law um that
would certainly help to clarify things
and take a lot of that subjectivity out
of it so that that's all I have for you
I appreciate your time thank you very
much major I
don't representative Shear um I don't
know if you're familiar the statute
unsworn falsification statute yes sir um
how does this overlap with
that um in that many of the allegations
that are are leveled in the cases that
would I think fall into consideration
were this statute to be uh to be enacted
uh the statements are not sworn at the
time that they're given and so unsworn
falsification wouldn't be invoked
necessarily um follow up followup I'm
sorry I maybe I'm I'm confus the the
statute I'm referring to I don't have
the number in front of me but there's a
statute that
says put unsworn falsification that is
the statement isn't sworn to when it's
given but it's a falsification there's
already a statute that deals with that
um my concern is that
this uh this overlaps that substantially
and I'm not sure what the need for this
is um in in given the unsworn
falsification stat yes sir uh fair
question and i' I'd actually lead that
to the to the sponsor or
sir that would probably be something we
would be able to discuss at the
executive session if we wanted to it it
could also be noted that some
allegations are are uh so significant as
to constitute allegations of criminal
conduct on the part of law enforcement
and there's a statute that covers that
as well false reports of to law
enforcement thank thank you very much
all
right is there anybody else here wishing
to testify on House Bill 109 that is not
turned in their pink card seeing none we
will close the public
hearing uh just so everybody is aware if
anybody's watching at home um House Bill
109 I'm sorry House Bill 146 that we
have scheduled for 12:00 if there is
anybody here today that wishes to
testify on that we are going to of of
course let them give their testimony
because it is scheduled for today but we
are going to give a professional
courtesy to that sponsor and we are
going to basically have a continuance of
that hearing um Friday the 7th and it's
actually going to be at 9:30 in the
morning a little bit earlier than we
usually do things um so basically we'll
you know if there is somebody here we'll
let them testify but we're going to
recess and just do a continuance next
week
so that's correct because the sponsor um
has has asked us to do that for them and
we've agreed to do that so just
today Ju Just to be very brief Just for
information for the committee the UN
uncorn falsification statute is RSA
6413 thank you all right we will be in
recess until
12:00 and we'll take it um from there to
six
e
good afternoon welcome back we are
opening the public hearing for House
Bill
146 um just for those of you that were
not here earlier did not hear the
earlier announcement the sponsor of this
bill did ask if we could please recess
and reschedule this hearing those of you
that are here we are certainly going to
let you testify and speak on behalf of
the bill but just so everybody knows we
are going to recess and do a continuance
um at
9:30 next Friday which I believe is the
you're all set representative Pro good
morning Madam chair and the committee
I'm here to just introduce Bill 146 as
the prime sponsor is unable to make it
uh as I understand it it is a bill
designed to keep video
evidence longer for
violations where it is not kept very
long for just a violation
that's all I know and no I am not taking
questions thank you representative proof
Manion thank you madam chair members of
the committee representative Dennis
Manion Rock 25
Salem uh I oppose this uh
bill um for the simple reason that this
is already being done so
violations where there are charges
clearly being uh made are already kept
for a minimum of three years um anything
that has a court case
pending um we're required to keep the
keep these uh body cameras for a minimum
of three
years um what we do is in the system I
work with axon and I work with watch God
in the past we set up retention rules in
advance so for an arrest we would have
minimum of years for a call for service
we're allowed no sooner than 30 days no
later than 180 days we usually set those
for 180 so there's certain uh time
frames that we have preset in the system
so anytime there's a there's an arrest
or a charge it's automatically preserved
for three years um at a
minimum so the retention rule we have a
separate one for traffic warnings and
traffic citation so if you're get if
you're issued a traffic citation in New
Hampshire technically that's no
different than an arrest you can be
arrested for a violation no Hampshire
but in Li of that they issue a what's
called a padded summons and you have a
an option of ping by mail or a
requesting a court date so in either
event though once that video comes in
that is tagged as uh arrest and that's
saved for a minimum of three years so
there's really no need for this the
other part of this is the request of the
camera recording within five
days this should be handled as Discovery
Quest and and taken care of through that
process uh we shouldn't be setting a
different day for 91a requests a
different day for body camera request
for violations and then a different day
for Discovery this is strictly
evidentiary for the persons who use in
court it's it should go through this
discovery process uh and the last part
of it really raises my eyebrows of
violation being dismissed if that's not
received within five days sounds a
little bit like somebody may have had a
run in and and looking to get their
charges dropped so I don't I don't
understand the purpose of that but for
for those reasons um I oppose this
representative I don't see any questions
looks like you got off scotf free look
and injuri good afternoon my name is
Stephen ERS I'm an assistant County
Attorney at the marac county attorney's
office I've been a prosecutor for over
20 years I also uh oppose House Bill 146
I certainly understand that RSA 105 D2
which is the body warn camera statute
has a couple of shortcomings and some
ambiguity in it especially when it comes
to providing Discovery in in criminal
cases those issues are hopefully being
addressed by another Senate Bill there
was a bill last year that went to a
study committee at the uh law
enforcement accreditation commission at
police St and training who wrote a
report making some recommendations as a
result of those recommendations there's
a Senate Bill pending that would look at
all cases not just violation level cases
and not just cases under RSA 265 which
is the motor vehicle code so this bill
itself only applies to violations under
265 meaning if you got a speeding ticket
you'd be entitled to receive the body
warant camera within 5 days but if for
example you got charged with Class B
misdemeanor driving well intoxicated you
would then go back to the normal sort of
Discovery rules which wouldn't have that
time frame associated with it so it
doesn't make a ton of sense to me
personally that you get it within 5 days
for a speeding ticket but a more serious
crime you wouldn't necessarily get it
within 5 days I think this also raises
questions about multiple
charges uh you can certainly have a case
that perhaps started as a a speeding
ticket or something under 265 which
would be a violation and turned into
something else for example if the police
officer ended up finding drugs in the
vehicle uh it could be a much larger
stop and then I Echo the the sentiments
about the the penalty provision that
failure of law enforcement to disclose
the recording as required by this
subsection results in the case being
dismissed without pre with prejudice I'm
sorry uh my concern is that of course in
New Hampshire body War cameras aren't
mandatory and I it seems like at least
from the introduction when I was here a
couple weeks ago representative Sher had
asked essentially how do we encourage
police departments to use bodyw warn
cameras and to me if you're a police
department a police chief and you're
wondering whether or not I should equip
my my officers with body Waring cameras
and you're told that if you do equip
them with body War cameras you're then
under this obligation to to hand the
body wearing camera recording out within
5 days and if you don't do that your
case is going to be dismissed with
prejudice it seems to me that that does
not necessarily incentivize law
enforcement to uh adopt body warant
cameras in general so for a number of
reasons I am opposed to this bill and
happy to answer
questions representative Sher Again full
disclosure uh Mr Enders had the
missfortune of also being a student of
mine um what's the name of the the
number of the uh bill in the Senate
that's being worked on it's Senate Bill
289 thank
you representative
lels thank you for taking my question
I'm not this is not necessarily specific
to the bill but if if a police
department um provides body War cameras
to their Law Enforcement
Officers um
I think that that uh video can can work
a couple of different ways it can Pro
protect the officer or it can protect
the person that uh uh that's being
charged is is there
any
statute that disallows a police officer
from turning off the camera
Cera yes there is yes so RSA 105
D2 is the state sort of compre I I think
it's a very comprehensive statute
regarding body War cameras it requires
the police to activate them upon arrival
or as soon as practicable it requires
the police to inform the person that
they're being recorded it requires that
essentially once the recording is
activated that it be maintained
throughout the entire incident um it
allows
the recording to be muted under certain
circumstances for example when officers
are speaking to each other whether
they're sort of forming a plan or that
type of thing they're allowed to mute it
so there's a fairly comprehensive
statute already in New Hampshire
regarding body warn cameras that that
statute has a couple of sections that
that first section is the the creation
of the body Waring camera in the field
and then the second sections of 105 D2
deal with how that recording is
maintained once it's made and there's
restrictions in that statute on copying
displaying viewing that body warn camera
which the legislature put in place
because they were concerned about
privacy of individuals on body warn
cameras and then the last section of
that statute talks about retention of
the body warrant cameras and in a little
bit of a sort of an odd twist normally
retention statutes say you have to keep
it for at least this amount of time RSA
105 D2 says You Must Destroy it within
certain time frames so again I think
that's a result of wanting to protect
people's privacy and not have these
things hanging around forever there are
situations as the gentleman before me
indicated that if charges are brought
they're they're held for a minimum
amount of time they're held till the
case is over so to prevent body War cam
from just being destroyed before a full
um a judicatory
I don't see any more questions thank you
very
much is there anybody here wishing to
testify on House Bill 146 that has not
turned in a paint card seeing none I
will
recess the public hearing and we will
reconvene that uh next Friday uh the
committee will be in recess until 1:30
and then we will come back and here
houseb 698 what's that oh all right
lunch
e
good afternoon everybody welcome back I
hope everybody enjoyed their lunch um we
are going to open the public hearing for
house Bill
698 and I would like to inter welcome
legislation okay um when you're finished
if you would not mind just filling out
the pink card so our clerk has it for
her meticulous
records yeah yeah a lot of people you
can mess with in this but not
if you don't mind just there you go
thank
you there you go the red red means go in
this committee I got it um so this bill
is very simple um and it is
just it is uh intended to address uh
largely a safety issue but to some
degree an accountability issue um there
have been news headlines over the years
in various uh districts I don't uh
haven't seen any in New Hampshire but
I've certainly seen them in other states
where uh people commit home invasions or
commit other acts they um pull someone
over for speeding which becomes a
pretext for a carjacking or something um
by posing as a police officer um and
people can do this uh just because uh
there are not requirements for
identification or um police are not
restricted from exercising their police
powers only when they're in uniform so
this is a simple modification um that
says that when a officer is in uniform
everything is same as it is now when an
officer is out of uniform um and he's
undercover and it's pre-approved
everything is the same as now so you
know I say you know uh let's deal some
drugs you're not a cop are you the cop
says no of course not uh and that's fine
and um in exing circumstances there are
no need to hold up your ID before you're
kicking in a door or something uh
however if someone says hey you know I'm
a cop and this person is dressed in a
T-shirt and uh you know I need to see
your ID I need your social security
number uh you can legitimately say hey
are you actually a cop can I see your ID
and um that is the only requirement and
so this should not be a problem for any
legitimate um law enforcement officer um
and there should be uh the finance
committee has said that there should be
no budget impact and I'm open to any
questions thank you um so when you said
about social security number that was
just an example right I don't it was an
example of something I saw um in a uh
YouTube channel the civil rights lawyer
just the other day day uh where people
claiming to be uh ice agents asked
someone hey prove you're an American
citizen let me see your ID I'm going to
take a picture of it what's your social
security number and this is a tool for
potentially uh identity theft you aren't
kidding this just gives someone the
ability to say you know I don't know
what the laws I don't know if I have to
ID myself I'm certainly going to comply
with every legal order can I just see
your ID first oh you're an officer
you're an ice agent you're FBI great now
I will answer your
questions interesting thank you
you okay somebody has to have their hand
up
here representative Shar I have to keep
my record going um what's the difference
between
10428a and this addition 10428
b
um I remember discussing that with uh OS
I believe the answer is that
um could you rem the text of a please uh
a says any person who knowingly and
falsely assumes or exercise of functions
Powers duties or privilege incident to
the office of sheriff and that goes
through a whole list uh or who wears or
displays without Authority any uniform
badge or identification by which Etc and
with the intent of to being recognized
as such shall be guilty of a Class B
felonies I'm just trying to figure out
right what we gain with this um so um
just one second thank you for the
gentleman who shared this with
me uh so part of it is that a requires
the intent to exercise uh privileges or
Powers so I'm putting you under arrest
um and this would be uh just you know I
I just want to have a conversation with
you
um and you know police are allowed to
have a conversation and there's a lot of
hold
saying hey you were not being detained
it was not in uh exercise of police
Powers um because it was a voluntary
conversation between a citizen and
another citizen who happens to be a
police
officer followup
followup
um whenever police officer asks
someone uh uh says I want to ask you
some
questions uh
and the person says no if the police
officer
then um uh says well I'm I'm going to
hold you here until you answer some
questions at at that point under the law
the officer the the the individual is
detained I agree and the exercise of
that
Authority uh to detain the person
briefly which they're allowed to do
under certain
circumstances uh I'm just
not still not sure what we get with 28b
sure um so I I think I'm I'm not a
lawyer but I think that might be a Terry
stop that we're both talking about um
unfortunately I am a
la I I passed the bar exam by deciding
not to go to law school um so the you
know there is the whole thing about am I
being detained and the officer you know
doesn't answer that um Etc and so uh
this is um triggered this bill is
triggered in part by an incident that
happened uh to a friend of mine uh
Jeremy calman who was at his home and
two people came up to his front door uh
Dressed in civilian clothing and said we
are FBI agents and we have some
questions and um I think that Jeremy
asked them for identification and they
Shrugged it off um I and four other
three other Representatives wrote To The
Head of the FBI division uh
headquartered in Boston which covers New
Hampshire and uh said hey we are state
representatives a constituent of one of
ours an acquaintance of the rest uh had
this incident where two people not in
uniform without an identification who
did not give their names who did not
give their badge numbers claimed to be
FBI agents can you tell us if these
people were FBI agents and further can
you tell us what your Protocols are I
mean you know maybe your Protocols are
explicitly there's three tiers there's
undercover there's you know FBI inform
whatever um can you tell us if these
people were FBI agents and what your
Protocols are for displaying information
uh or identification when requested and
we got no response uh we escalated a few
times and asked again and we got no
response
um
so this is a thing where in this
particular case uh this individual was
not detained he was on his front step
but um nonetheless there was a situation
and I suggest that with a law like this
in place uh there would be no
interference with investigative
abilities if if these were real FBI
agents they could have said yes of
course we are here are our badges uh
this would have been useful for Jeremy
in this case you know he could have
taken a quick picture uh so that if he
had a civil rights lawsuit or anything
later he would know what was happening
so you know we can also talk about the
scenario you know we've talked about the
one scenario where it's criminals posing
as law enforcement agents we can talk
about another uh scenario where they are
legitimate law enforcement agents either
conducting a mission that was not
authorized by their superiors or
exceeding the scope uh knowledgeable in
the fact that if the complaint comes in
later there were two bearded gentlemen
in their 30s wearing clothes you know
that's the identification um and you
know in this case Jeremy did have video
so that provided extra detail but in
many cases people aren't running their
cameras and especially it's fairly
common for law enforcement officers with
or without legal authority to tell
citizens stop filming so you can imagine
a scenario where someone is you know
pulled over or accosted at the street or
they're in Costco and someone claims to
be you know uh uh immigration control or
FBI or whatever wants to have a quick
conversation the you know maybe a person
you know and I've unfortunately been on
the receiving end of this you know I
know what my rights are I know a Terry
stop I you know can ask if I'm being
detained or not I can ask if that's a
lawful command or just a request I can
ask if I'm free to go uh but most
Americans are not fully cognizant of
their
rights um but you know if you you know
see TV uh real citizens know that they
do have to be read their rights this is
a fairly simple thing to ask and
similarly uh in New Hampshire you know
can I see your ID is a very simple thing
and at that point you know maybe the
actual Law Enforcement Officers showed
their ID but become cognizant of hey he
knows my name now I'd better play it by
the book and follow regulations um or
say uhoh you know this is I I've gotten
out over my skis I'm doing something I
shouldn't and they turn and walk away um
and even in that latter case uh that
would be under this a crime to say I'm a
law enforcement officer I'm you know
giving you a command or you know I want
to have a conversation but then
scurrying away so this would uh Bill if
passed would serve as a deterrent to uh
that sort of behavior which does in fact
happen follow up
I'm a law enforcement
officer I and I give you a command I'm
I'm a fake law enforcement officer thank
God for everybody um and I give you a
command uh to do
something to me that's covered by
10428a I'm a person who falsely is ex
knowingly or and falsely exercises the
functions of a police officer I I agree
with you so so my hypothetical where I
uh included the statement gives a
command um muddied my hypothetical and
brought it into something that is in
fact covered by a so I again want to you
know talk about situations where there
is not an explicit command but merely
someone claims to be and uses that as
sort of implicit pretext and there's a
lot of case law um where you know judges
at a great remov and with their sort of
socioeconomic privilege can say well you
know anyone who's you know sat through
torts or Criminal or whatever would
realize that the correct thing to say at
this juncture is such and such and the
citizen did not walk away from the
police officers therefore the citizen
was indicating that he was fully
voluntarily engaged in a mutually
agreeable activity um I I I think that
those hypotheticals miss a lot of the
sort of emotions and subjective
experience that happen uh with facts on
the ground and you know normal people uh
engaged in interactions with people who
either are or who claim to be Law
Enforcement Officers um so uh if if I
can adjust the hypothetical to you know
remove the command and just you know hey
uh you know I'm from Ice uh I want to
you know not not a command but I want to
see this can you tell me where you were
born etc etc um you know is a thing that
does in fact happen both with legitimate
Leos and
you everybody good all right seeing no
further questions thank you very much
thank you for your
good
afternoon uh ladies and gentlemen I
appreciate your time my name is Brendan
Davey I'm a major with the New Hampshire
State Police I am the commander of our
operations Bureau I'm here representing
the Department of Safety
in objecting to uh this bill as written
um line of questioning has has already
uh
revealed uh to some extent that uh the
law if uh if enacted that this law would
be largely obviated by existing law
unnecessary um there are also issues of
exigency not addressed by this law in
that um the exercise of police power is
um in many cases bereft of opportunities
to uh exchange identification things of
that nature particularly when to do so
is to expose the officer who may be off
duty in an official uh capacity at the
time that that these interactions could
occur and um furthermore there are
situations in which we use our
Undercovers uh to track uh to tail as it
were uh and to confront in some cases
very dangerous people who at the site of
uniform police officers would behave in
manners that would subject themselves
and the officers and others to
unjustifiable risk
um the the notion that a police officer
would approach someone and ask them for
their social security number I I find
um very very unlikely uh in this state
in particular and I would add to that
that
um two things that that were addressed
the
uh the profession of law enforcement as
a profession largely controls uh the
behavior of its members with standard
operating procedures many of which uh
are akin to the one that we have in the
New Hampshire State Police which
includes when asked for our name our
badge number as it were then we're to
uh the the idea that uh filming would be
that a person would be told to stop
filming um it that's a a very well
settled matter of law uh within this
state I'm a Public Employee you can film
me as long as you like provided that it
doesn't uh subject us uh to unnecessary
risk basically or get in the way of the
lawful activity so um that is my those
are are uh my responses to uh to matter
spoken and the and the Department's view
legislation thank you very much
Newman I just have a comment about the
I'm comparing this
bill to the current law and the the
current law talks about any person in
and then says they they do this and and
displays a uniform without
Authority this bill says any person
while not wearing their official uniform
see so it to me I think that narrows it
down just to someone who has a uniform
or has an identification just the
wording of
it I'm wondering if that would just
narrow this down from any person that
wording might narrow it down just to
someone who has those documents in
clothing and I understand your point sir
um I can answer with a with an
experience that I had of arresting a a
drunk driver in my neighbor's driveway
after he got stuck there after making a
100o turn in my other neighbor's
driveway it was a a Friday night it was
uh 10:00 at night I ran out there in my
jeans and and T-shirt with my gun on my
hip and uh convinced him more by virtue
of my conduct uh that I was law
enforcement but had I been required at
that point to to show him some ID and
satisfy um
his demand of me to prove who I was at
that point um we would have had a
different kind of situation more of a
stalemate I suppose so um your point is
is well taken and generally generally
speaking we do have ID with us and and
we do uh let people know who we are
without without delay follow up sure
yeah just a f a follow-up comment to
that I was TR I wasn't trying to reply
what a police officer might do or might
not do yes sir I was trying to say that
if this bill replaced the other one it
would it would limit it would limit it
to people that actually had a uniform
and had whatever could be the only
people that would be subject to the new
B new law where the other one includes
all any person that tries to impersonate
an officer MH anyway I'll leave it at
that thank you yes sir so major if if I
if I may
ask how would this
affect a an officer
maybe maybe an off duty officer you know
you know the the famous movie scenes
right you're at the diner and Pulp
Fiction right you're at the diner and
something's about to go
down tell her to chill and
now what would H like what would happen
I
I what would happen because you're not
in uniform right right but you're
clearly an officer and now you have this
Duty how would that how would this
affect
it the way that I read it as written it
places the burden on me to prove to that
person before they will submit to my
exercise of authority that I am a
person uh vested with powers that they
ought to recognize and uh to obey in
order for their conduct to
be either lawful or at least not uh
unlawful further okay so it's
um that's really the issue is in the
midst of a of an evolving tactical
situation uh to say you just keep their
your hands where they are and then I'll
produce my ID for you is uh an untenable
circumstance to be in furthermore it the
courts have ruled that that merely to
speak to people in public under certain
circumstances can be viewed as as a
detention and so um the extent to which
we walk by someone on the sidewalk and
just talk about the weather and say
hello and leave it at that uh versus ask
a
question about the fact that we're in a
business that's closed and it's at night
um the those are all issues that are
always taken into consideration by the
court so what is at the end of the day
an exercise of power is uh or authority
is very carefully scrutinized by the
court so at what point in reality my
exercising my authority would then be
subject to my satisfying the Curiosity
of the person who is subject to that
Authority that I am who I say I am um
that clearly is a is problematic
down representative Sabor D Schwaner
thank
you thank you madam Shar sir thank you
for my question um is there already an
anti-harassment law on the books that
might cover this already like the
example that was
given know that certainly by
representative corkran that it was a
definitely harassment is there was this
is this adding to would this be adding
um a law I'm not sure I can say with
confidence for people who we this
uniform to have conducted themselves in
that way um would subject them to uh at
least internal
repercussions uh whether or not the
conduct was illegal based on the
description I it strikes me as
impersonation and clearly there's a law
uh that makes that illegal but um
harassment I'm I'm not really the
no I've been informed that this is an
addition and not a replacement yes sir
and so I'd like to go back to the
scenario that you described
and looking at this um in the instance
that you describe since this says any
person not wearing their official
uniform so they don't have but they
actually do have if it says without
their official uniform it says the
person must be someone who has an
official uniform and then fails to
provide to fails to wear it and fails to
provide identity would then be subject
to a class B
felony and I think that language is just
kind of crazy it just it because it
limits it to the police and I'm not sure
what the intent to accomplish with this
because it all it's also goes on and
says to say uh uh it has a carve out for
any officer who is a law enforcement and
engaged in undercover
activity you know so I just think this
is all about official police that don't
produce their identity in or wear their
uniform and I just don't think that this
would be enforcable or wise do you do
you agree with that or do you I do sir
you well and
it uh engaged in legitimate who
determines what's legitimate and the
pre-approval approved by whom so it's a
sir thank you very much major I think I
think we're on the same page thank you
mad thank you very
much is there anybody else here that
wishing to testify on house bills six
something 698 that has not turned into
pink card seeing none I will close the
public hearing and let's see we have
about looks like 7 minutes until uh 2:00
e
okay
so all right welcome back um we are
going to open up the public hearing for
House Bill
162 and
welcome representative Sher to introduce
uh the bill uh thank you madam chair uh
I'm representative Buzz Sher I am uh
from Rockingham District 26 Port Smith
Ward
three uh not incidentally I'm um also a
police commissioner elected Police
Commissioner in Portsmouth where we the
three elected police Commissioners are
the board of directors for the police
department um this bill is uh the next
step in a process that began 3 or 4
years ago when uh representative Roy uh
and Senator then Senator Harold French
uh introduced
bills one in the house and one in the
Senate to uh require uh in written
informed consent uh when an officer uh
when a off when an officer searches a
car if if the person agrees to have the
car searched and Al it it alternatively
it required the officer before an
individual made the decision about
whether to consent or not to inform them
that they didn't have they had a
constitutional right not to consent and
that uh their refusal to consent to a
search of the motor vehicle would not be
held against them in any way um that was
the substance of that bill um and uh it
passed uh through both uh the house and
the Senate uh I believe on consent
calendar if I'm not mistaken um and this
is the next step in that bill um where
we just include all searches of property
where an officer uh is obtaining consent
to search it's like effectively uh I
think uh representative Roy referred to
it when he testified on this on the
earlier version of this he referred to
it as basically giving uh people who are
being asked to consent to search
something akin to Miranda rights U just
uh uh here are your constitutional
rights as to whether you have to consent
to search or not and uh so this is the
next step to uh finish off that uh uh
the scope of that bill um I I can only
speak for uh uh Portsmouth uh police but
uh it I I talked with the chief there
and this is a not this was a nonissue
for him
um I think many police departments
already do this um so uh there's the
testimony thank you very much
good representative Murphy thank you she
resist can you tell me thank you for
taking my question and I in all fairness
I haven't read this every single line of
this but what
um would this bill as written preclude
the ability of law enforcement to if a
person denied access to um to the trunk
of their
car what if and I'm just thinking
hypothetically they kidnapped somebody
and they're in the back of their truck
back of their car law enforcement if the
person then says no you can't you can't
search my car law enforcement then needs
to get a search warrant I'm assuming
correct uh in most circumstances there
can be circumstances where law
enforcement if they have probable cause
to search the car they may not under
certain circumstances need to go get a
search warrant but what they could do if
they needed to get a search warrant uh
they again this all depends on the
circumstances they could seiz the car
temporarily while they went and got the
search
warrant okay but this doesn't get in the
way of that process this just says when
they're looking for consent they have to
let the person know uh that they have a
constitutional right not to consent and
if they decide to consent get that in
writing or on a body Camp so this
doesn't get in a way of anything a
police officer could do based on uh
knowledge they had to get into the the
trunk of the car without consent so
should a person not consent under these
like exent circumstances the police
officer can still get into that Tru yeah
I'm too much of a professor so depending
on the specific circumstances yes
sometimes they' have to get a search
warrant sometimes they would I I I I
just want to be accurate in describing
the law but this doesn't get in the way
either way of
since this bill encompasses it it looks
like it encompasses all property would
that include things uh like electronic
equipment like computers and cell
phones uh yes I mean mean it's already
uh the US Supreme Court has already
decided that uh even if the police found
your cell phone on the side of the road
and there could pick it up as what
seemed to be abandoned property um or
they came across the your cell phone
legally through a search incident to
arrest which they're allowed to do the
US Supreme Court has said nonetheless to
get into the cell phone they need to get
a search warrant unless they have
consent I mean they could get consent
and this would this and and and they
that's what would apply this would apply
to they would have to say simply you
have the right not to give us
consent um and uh if you do give us
consent please sign up here if you
decide not to give us consent uh we're
not going to hold against you doesn't
get in the way of them go getting a
search warrant if they have the
necessary problem
cost right see no more further questions
thank you very much oh I didn't see your
hand I
apologize it was an accident I'm working
on it representative gther I feel like
an irresistible Target just wanted can
we go to line um 18 says a significant
period of time shall mean the person in
the law enforcement agency involved has
ceased to interact with one another and
a new set of circumstances or facts have
Arisen that justify a new interaction
can you explain that to me or give me an
example yeah there yeah I'll give you an
example of a US Supreme Court case
please go up to a house husband they
want to search the house they don't have
problem caed they don't have a warrant
they can't get into the house the
husband and wife answer the door the uh
husband
says uh they asked for consent to search
the house to come into the house and the
husband says no the wife says yes the
Supreme Court
said if one person says no that's
enough the police then detain the
husband short time later for other
reasons and take him away then they go
back to the house and ask for consent
from the wife and she consent
and they find a bunch of incriminating
information US Supreme Court said that's
fine if the person is Spirited Away
there are circumstances where the police
May return to the house or they may
acquire further
information and they may come back and
say to the
individual hey we know this now now do
you want to let us
consent and uh if the person says you
know they've got to inform them again of
these rights but what that language does
is
it it tries to create prevent the
police from getting a warrant coming
back well no it doesn't try to prevent
from getting a warrant they can always
get a warrant tries to prevent the
police from just coming back every 10
minutes without a change in
circumstances to keep trying to get
consent trying to put pressure on in
that way that's what that language is
intended to account for so that doesn't
happen it's fine if the circumstances
are changed they can come back and ask
for consent if they want or or they can
go get a search War if they want but we
don't want them coming back every five
or 10 minutes to keep trying without new
information that's a form of
intimidation that that we this tries to
deal
mic good afternoon my name is stepen
Anderson I'm an assistant County
attorney in Marat County um I've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years years and I
I do oppose this bill um in New
Hampshire all searches have to be
conducted pursuant to either a warrant
or an exception to that warrant
requirement consent is an exception to
the warrant requirement and consent that
exception has been developed over years
through case law um as representative sh
indicated he cited a number of Supreme
Court cases this is something that again
has been developed through case law
under our current case law there's no
requirement to inform a person that they
have the right to refuse consent under
our current case law there's also no
requirement that any type of written
form or anything like that be
required
as as representative Sher said this is
sort of like a Miranda for consent but
this actually goes much further than
Miranda rights go because
currently in New Hampshire there's no
requirement that Miranda rights be
written down or that we have a form uh
formally waving them so this actually
goes beyond that it doesn't just require
it's to be informed it requires that
aning to be in writing or on body warn
camera that creates difficulties because
there may be times when the officer
doesn't have the form with them or
doesn't have a body warn camera and then
would simply be precluded from asking
for consent because you don't have a
form the language in the bill itself is
actually
um I think confusing and I say that
because under current 595 A10 which is a
statute I'm certainly not in love with
um section one that starts online five
says a law enforcement officer May
legally conduct a search of a person's
home or any other property including a
motor vehicle without a warrant if the
law enforcement officer expressly
informs the person of these two
things it seems odd to me that it
doesn't actually require the person a
consent it just requires the officer it
says the officer May legally conduct a
search if you say these two things
certainly that's not what it means it
means you actually have to have the
person agree to consent but it it
doesn't explicitly say
that the form itself under paragraph
three at line
24 says that the form itself needs to
provide notice of the provisions of
paragraphs one and two so the way this
ends up working is if this passed and it
came to me I'd be tasked with creating a
consent form for the police departments
within the county and I can tell you
that what I would do is simply cut and
paste paragraphs 1 and two so that there
was no question that my form um complied
with the statute if I did that my form's
going to include the language in
paragraph two if the per if if you
refuse to consent to a search the law
enforcement officer shall cease any
further questioning concerning consent
to search unless a significant period of
time has passed
or you rais the subject of consent a
significant period of time shall mean
the per and law enforcement agency
involved have ceased to interact with
one another in a new set of
circumstances or facts have arisen that
justify new
interaction I think that just becomes
form the other concern I have about this
bill and it's similar to the concern I
expressed before is that there's this
exclusionary provision in
it that
says um any search that violates this
section will result in the evidence
being excluded
what concerns me about that is the
exclusionary rule is a fairly severe
remedy that is employed for
constitutional
violations whereas here we're not
talking about necessarily a
constitutional violation we're talking
about a statutory
violation um if the officer doesn't use
the right form doesn't have a form but
does in fact obtain what would normally
be
regular good consent we're suppressing
all the evidence as a result result of
that and I I think that certainly
excluding all evidence is a is a is a
major um a major hurdle uh for a
statutory violation i' be happy to
answer
questions thank you very
much that was actually very nice
explanation thank you trying to write as
quickly as you were giving the
information anybody have any questions I
we're all good all right looks like
we're all set thank you very much
appreciate your
time is there anybody else that is here
that wishes to testify for House Bill
162 that has not completed a pink card
seeing none I will close the public
hearing and our before anybody leaves um
our next hearing is at
2:30 um but representative gaite and I
uh discussed it and we think it'd be a
good idea to just do an executive
session
on House
Bill
698 so going to give the clerk a second
e
this
for
e
welcome back everybody we are going to
open the public hearing for House Bill
468 and we welcome representative
wheeler to discuss this legislation
thank you madam chair friend and
colleagues on the house criminal justice
and Public Safety Committee for the
record my name is Jonah Orion wheeler I
represent the towns of Peter bro and
Sharon Hillsboro's 33rd District uh I am
a sponsor on HB
468 uh and I'm here to fill the as
representative RADS said the big shoes
of Representative Roy who I'm sure is
watching at home and I hope I do a good
job for him here today I was already
planning on testifying but but now here
I am introducing the bill so I'm happy
to take any questions that you may have
HP 468 addresses a gap in the law around
the regulations for use of an unmanned
aerial vehicle and
drone these drones are being used a lot
more often as we saw in 2024 November
13th to now they're still being seen in
the air there was a significant increase
of drone incursions over the East Coast
the West Coast you saw on December 13th
and December 17th right Patterson Air
Force Base in Ohio was shut down because
of these drones on 11 December Chinese a
Chinese National was arrested outside of
vanderberg vanderberg Air Force Base for
flying one of these drones uh the
legislation sets up a tiered system
whereby somebody who was lying a Joan
unlawfully against FAA regulations for
their first time would
be guilty of a violation for the first
offense a misdemeanor for a subsequent
offense that's F that's found on lines
12 through
15 the next
paragraph
has outlines the system by which if
someone is interfering with human
occupied aircraft or other wising
impeding the normal course of operations
of international Regional municipal or
general aviation airports that that
person would be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor and a class B felony if such
operation resulted in the damage of a
human occupied aircraft and a class a
felony if that was resulted in the the
damage of a human human occupied
aircraft alongside serious death or or
injury so I think this tiered system
that we have set up here is
pretty moderated I think the penalties
are appropriate for the crimes that they
uh have committed if you're flying a
drone in airports airspace and your
drone you know people think oh it's just
a small drone it's it's no problem but
if you know anything about aircraft air
travel if that plane's coming down at
hund and some odd miles an hour 130ish
and they're about to land and a drone is
in its flight path that drone could go
right through the fusil lodge right
through uh the engine and and create
some very serious problems and we've
seen that happen in the instances in
which a drone has crashed into a plane
or or something or the other so this is
a serious crime the skies should be
protected and open the United States I
think loves its air travel we should be
making air travel safer and more secure
and not not littering our skies with
these drones that are operating in many
instances illegally
so happy to take any questions about
this piece of legislation and the
specifics around it but I hope at some
level that the committee is able to find
some way to to fill this Gap and I think
HB 468 fills it properly thank you madam
chair thank you representative
um I believe you covered it but I just
wanted to to clarify if I may so when we
had this
legislation last term I believe it was a
a Senate bill and and representative
Newman actually got us a very quick
Amendment because it I think if I'm not
mistaken it went like misdemeanor felony
felony and we wanted to make it
violation you know misdemeanor felony
and then our other friends came back and
they didn't do that and I did away with
it on the house floor and may have been
heckled by that by some of my other
friends so this is now addressing the
concern that that we at least had in
this committee last year of let's step
right like Step Up the Ladder instead of
you know going over jump off the cliff
jump absolutely yeah absolutely Madam
chair I remember that legislation and I
thought to myself why is the criminal
justice committee dealing with drones
and unmanned aircraft here but it
actually became clear in research that
this is something that's uh and I think
yes this legislation addresses the
concerns that we had on this committee
last spum and and moves us forward in a
way that hopefully we won't have to
throw it off the cliff again
thank you thank you
representative representative suborn
yeah you that was a good try thank you
madam Sherman I have to keep my note out
that tells me how to say
it representative wheeler much much
simpler last name by the way um so the
only restrictions on
flight anywhere it appears it's just you
can fly your drone anywhere except over
a federal State Correctional
item number four correct that's the
only that can be flown that's correct
okay or otherwise regulated by the FAA
so you can fly at your house unless your
house becomes an FAA no fly zone for
some reason or the other you know but
thank
you if you live airp right would the
bill Encompass flying a drone over
private property you don't
own that's a good question
representative Muse I would say that if
you fly that would be a different piece
of the law than than the law trying to
protect the aircraft and the airspace
itself I would be interested in trying
to
address flying drones over private
property when you don't have the
permission of that person who's owns the
property and I know that came up in the
conversations last year how do we
identify what drone where that's coming
from um but I think that would be maybe
a separate piece of legislation but
happy to whatever you in the committee
feels is necessary on this thank you
thank
you would you believe that when I was on
Edna we addressed a lot of those things
about drones flying over people's houses
and taking pictures you take pictures as
long as they were not
recognizable if I remember correctly I
would believe that and I'm going to have
research representative Shear do do you
know if
uh the commercial entities that sell
these
drones accompany the sale with some
notification of what the fa FAA
regulations are I mean you know I'm a
little my guess is the average lay
person who may buy a drone because it's
kind of fun and interesting they have no
clue whatsoever what the f FAA
regulations are I would say ignorance is
not an excuse that's absolutely right
and I would say
I've never bought one of those drones
that are very expensive now I haven't
even looked because they're so expensive
I know I'm not even going to give my S
you know I'd love to have one of those
drones so I'm not even going to look but
what I can say is there there are tear
of those drones I do know that and the
drones that are readily available um are
often times not the ones that would stay
up long enough or be able to
fly uh high enough to cause these kind
of problems and and I guess I would say
like representative Road said I keep
wanting to call you representative Roy
cuz that's the name tag right in front
of you but but like representative Road
said uh that there you go um the not
knowing is not is not a reason enough
not to be compliant if you're if you're
choosing to fly an aircraft you should
you should know that there are
regulations for our skies and especially
if you're living around an airport or an
FAA regulated area yeah I'm not so
concerned with the living around an
airport or a penal institution or house
Corrections followup representative sh
followup I'm sorry my concern is you
know the the set paragraph two um I mean
you know and I know that probably most
of the people that buy their first Grown
have no clue what the limits are and it
would be you know as a a matter of
notice it would be nice to have do you
think it would be nice to have them uh
be aware of what those regulations are
absolutely and as you were talking I was
thinking of myself you know conversation
that I had with representative Harriet
goth right outside before this she asked
where is the feds on this and I would
say that's something that the federal
government should encourage companies
which are producing these drones to make
sure that there is a notice that says
you should follow and comply with FAA
regulations if you are to fly one of
these aircraft thank you thank
you I would be interested to see how
many people actually read the notices
you know don't remove your tag from your
nutrition labels right representative n
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question um I'm just curious
and looking through so the difference
between a Class A a class B felony and a
class a felony is just to quote really
quickly a class B felony if uh such
operation results in damage to a human
occupied air uh aircraft in flight and
then class a felony is if such operation
causes said air said aircraft to crash
and such crash results in death or a
serious bodily injury so what's
interesting to me about that and I would
love for you to comment on it is the
difference between a Class A Class B and
a Class A is whether serious bodily
injuries is it's not the if you cause
let me try and say it better because I
would think that regardless if you
caused a manned uh aircraft to crash
whether or not the person sustained
serious bodily injury would think it
would be the same level of felony you
know what I mean so the separation is in
what harm came of it to the individual
rather than the fact that you could have
caused that harm it just didn't happen
to happen you know what I mean I think I
yes and um I would say the class B
felony is just such that you would be
guilty of a class B felony if the human
occupied craft were damaged but still
flyable so there are instances in which
you know a drone could hit a craft that
craft could still land properly and that
person would be fine in which case class
B felony but if the Drone or whatever
aircraft is being operated crashes into
the craft that CRA that craft then
crashes it's human occupied then that
person would be a class a felony I think
that's where the distinction comes if if
the craft can still if it's just damaged
but it can still land it hasn't crashed
then then it's not as high as a class a
felony I think that's where the
distinction came in but I'm not the
drafter for can I follow up real quick
because the place where it says crash is
in section c there or the you know that
Clause where it's talking about if it
causes it to crash and the Crash results
so it's just interesting to me that it's
separated in that way because I think if
it crashed and didn't cause because the
and is in there if it crashed and it
didn't cause serious bodily injury or a
death then it would still be included in
damage the way that I'm reading it maybe
I'm okay I think I see what you're
saying now so you're
saying a person would be guilty of a uh
a class a felony if the operations
caused the aircraft to crash and if that
crash resulted in death or serious
bodily
injuries I would still say that those
are different than the class B felonies
because the class B felony is such that
it's just damage of the of the airc
the class a felony comes when that
aircraft crashes and such crash result
in death or serious bodily injury okay
I'm happy to talk with you a little bit
more afterwards about
proof oh yeah so I do believe that when
you buy a drone the basic Federal FAA a
warning is in the Box you can only fly
so high you have to be so far away from
an airport or an inclusion
Zone
yep representative
Muse one of the things that we talked
about uh when we talked about a similar
Bill last year was sort of the the
weaponization of drones so the the bill
it doesn't look like it would cover
things like somebody the Drone into a
person like injuring a person
intentionally with a drone releasing a
package that would injure a person you
know and I know in Manchester there was
an issue with somebody dropping fe's on
some homeless people with a drone in
Ukraine they're dropping things that are
a lot worse on people and so that Bas
that the technology is for this has
really kind of come a long way in a year
and the the ability you know to actually
do harm to people
um would one of the things that just
occurs to me is in the part where we
make a class a felony in addition maybe
to causing the aircraft to crash uh you
know and having that result in serious
death or B bodily injury it's it could
be the the intentional misoperation of
the Drone itself you know or uh use of
the Drone um you know to to basically
harm another human being uh it seems
like would be an appropriate addition
I'm just wondering what you would think
of that I I would agree I think that
would be an appropriate addition when
you see those videos of the people in
the trenches in Ukraine and they're just
sitting there and then the buzzing of
the drones around I mean drone Warfare
is one of the most horrific things that
we're seeing these days and the
weaponization of these drones is
concern representative PR it is already
unlockable in the state to weaponize a
would we believe that it's already
illegal in this state representative
Pro would we believe that it's already
illegal yes we believe thank you
representative right representative so
close representative Shear um I I was
provoked by representative proof um it
would it would be a uh it would be if a
somebody ran a drone intentionally into
a person and injured them that would be
a simple assault if they caused serious
bodily injury recklessly it would be a
class B
felony
Etc thank thank you guys remember we're
supposed to be asking
questions okay representative wheeler
welcome thank you nice to see you nice
to see you as well Madam chair for the
record my name is Helen Hanks I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections I'm here in support and
thank the sponsors of HB 468 FN um
you'll find in my testimony I won't read
it because I know you will read it and
take your time to review the information
I provided to you I have been working um
uh for a number of years to both at our
federal level and uh supporting at our
state level all the work to protect our
Correctional Facilities from uh I'm
going to use the term drones uh you'll
see numerous examples in other states
where drones across the country are
dropping um drugs Firearms cell phones
we do not have uh drone detection in New
Hampshire when we see a visual drone we
shut down our yard it is uh chaos we
look to see if something's been dropped
we're using you know our cameras and our
human eyes it is a challenge it is
unsafe um and I share that because there
should be a consequence and we are
mindful of uh individuals who do it
unknowingly
um and we work with our state police
partners and other partners in the state
to help us identify the operators of
those drones when we can uh but they are
really upping the game in our
Correctional spaces across the country
where these uh Contraband items have
resulted in loss of life dropping
firearms that are used to actually end
the life of individuals who are working
in these institutions in Georgia in
Idaho a cell phone was dropped to use uh
for escape that was successful uh the
list goes on and these protections are
appropriate when these uh drones are
used with Criminal Intent and the intent
to make things unsafe so I I thank you
for this opportunity and would also
share we did have a free pilot uh with a
drone partner and um and it was
literally free which was nice and uh we
did identify at least three drones that
had been flying over our correctional
facility on our Southern campus here and
and they did it um unknowingly and we
coached them but we really uh again need
this type of support I would be mindful
I do not oversee uh County jails but I
would point to line 26 and ask this
honorable committee to determine if it
covers our County uh jail Partners in
this formal legislation would that uh
Avail myself for
questions thank you we'll make sure we
make a note of line
26 you said just to make sure that they
also cover County facilities that we I
would I would hope that this committee
would want to provide that type of
resource to our County Jail Partners
thank you thank you representative sheer
question you have a question right yeah
I think I do thank thank
you um you mentioned drone detection
devices or systems are are there such
things and how much do they cost uh
representative share there certainly are
and they uh come with all different
price tags I can follow up with some uh
cost information we some Capital uh
budget proposals ago uh did ask for that
type of support we were off for
different type of relief we asked that
CLE year but I will get some updated
quotes for you do you have a followup do
you have a broad range of the price
spread on those representative Sher I
think if I gave you a number I would be
throwing a dart and I'd feel more
confident if I had more time fair enough
you any any other questions yeah
representative Pro in those systems do
they have a way to take the Drone down
uh my understanding is some of them do
uh some of them do I have not had that
validated to me yeah they definitely
identify where they are and before they
cover your uh come into your secure
perimeter and you can I then reverse uh
engineer the information to identify
where the operator is coming from but
your question is really important and
I've been told that they do but I'm not
yeah anybody else thank you very much
commissioner thank you everyone thank
you for joining us today St safe in your
travels
Christopher
Bell
Beal Mike oh is it ball M I'm sure thank
you yeah last name is Ball B A let just
make that you and a shall we whatever
works for you is fine with me I I get
all different different versions of it
so not offended in the slightest um my
name is Christopher ball I'm here to
represent the department of safety uh
specifically State Police I'm a member
of our Aviation unit um I I just want to
take a few brief moments of your time to
discuss this legislation um
representative wheeler and our
counterparts at Department of
Corrections I think have done a great
job so far laying the groundwork I just
have a couple uh additional things to
add um to to this um one one thing right
off the bat um is that this legislation
has been a collaborative effort amongst
uh all departments in the state here uh
including Department of Safety
Department of Transportation uh
Department of Corrections um it's been a
cumulative effort over the past two or
so years uh to put this legislation
together with perspectives from uh
different viewpoints um not only from
the state side of things but also our
public uh partners and uh private
Partners as well um to really draft uh
and come to a agreement on uh the
wording in this legislation to make it
uh comprehensible but also um you know
Fair across the board for everyone's
given
um different viewpoints um with that um
there is one uh at least technical
correction or Amendment I'd like to
propose for the uh legislation that's
before you I do have copies I think
available for all the members here of
the committee um I've s have highlighted
the area that we'd like to add some
language to was just a brief paragraph
uh reference to including um a penalty
for uh violating uh the operations of
law enforcement or firefighting or other
emergency responses uh in New Hampshire
uh and I'd be happy to pass that round
uh if that would be
appropriate if you just want to hand
that to representative Shear he'll be
I'm sure he'll be happy to pass it down
for
us thank
you and if there are are not enough
copies be happy to make some more uh and
certainly send them your way um so that
you'll notice when that comes around
there's a highlighted paragraph It's
paragraph two in the strata language uh
and that reads a person is guilty of a
misdemeanor if such person operates a
small uas that interferes with law
enforcement firefighting other emergency
response operations or violates any
provisions of RSA 6449 in 6449 uh the
New Hampshire RSA is speaking to our
privacy act um so we just want to make
sure that language uh was at least
considered and possibly included uh
going forward from from this point um so
just going back a little bit again this
is like a cumulative effort on the part
of of many stakeholders to get this
legislation before you um and
essentially what this legislation does
it gives New Hampshire law enforcement a
tool to fall back on as representative
wheeler mentioned uh really at this
point in time there is no New Hampshire
law uh regarding uas or nefarious uas
operations uh and that really ties the
hands of New Hampshire law enforcement
uh currently as it as it stands um so
this would give a option for law
enforcement if they do encounter
individuals who are using these for
nefarious purposes either um Criminal
Intent uh recklessly uh or carelessly um
obviously with the uh the the mindset
that you know any enforcement action um
would probably be uh you know pre pre uh
uh predisposed to any some kind of some
kind of like education along the way so
prior to take enforcement action uh
there' be some education involved so the
idea at least from our perspective is
not to um take enforcement action
broadly uh but only when it's
specifically needed and this would give
law enforcement in Hampshire the ability
to do that when that obviously that
those situations call for it um as
representative wheeler had mentioned
there's been a number of incidents
across the country globally and even
locally uh involving the nefarious use
of drones or The Reckless operation of
drones and that's why we think this
legislation in Hampshire is so
important um and with that I'd be happy
to take any questions thank you very
much representative
pette thank you I was just wondering if
the amendment that you just offered um
would include like um media related
drones and
things um Ju Just so I I understand the
question uh for so media Outlets that
may be flying drones over a uh scene or
something like like those lines correct
okay yes absolutely um that is not the
intent to restrict that from happening
um only if that conduct was interfering
with the Emergency Operations um for
instance um a recent event in California
with the uh wildfires a uh firefighting
aircraft was struck by a drone and you
know that obviously uh deterred that uh
aircraft from you know helping put out a
fire so things along those lines is what
we' be looking at uh preventing with
this
legislation but it would yeah you're
sorry but it wouldn't restrict media
from you know doing their job at some
sort of scene fire scene emergency scene
something like that no it wouldn't only
if it was interfering with the operation
of that scene thank you you're welcome
thank you just so every so everybody's
aware I know we have some uh new members
um what Mr ball has been kind enough to
give us is not actually an amendment
it's just some suggested verbiage that
he thinks might be helpful for us to add
to the bill if an amendment is done uh
representative MS
would you be open to changing your
suggested changes in the language so
that we could draft something that
doesn't actually preclude the media from
filming these scenes I think putting
guardrails around it is one thing um
when you eliminate it it's a freedom of
the press issue yes yeah we we would be
open to that and and and certainly it's
not uh the intent at least from our
perspective to preclude media from from
anybody else we good okay thank you very
levit thank you madam chair my name is
Jason levit I'm with nhdot I'm the uas
planner and I'm actually here to provide
technical information if if needed and I
would request that I could bring my
certainly
Sor if you could just please um
introduce yourself uh for the committee
and you guys are certainly welcome to do
this together sure um my name is Trisha
Lambert and I'm the bureau administrator
of I'm The Bu administrator of the
Bureau of Aeronautics for the the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
and um as Jason said he's he is our a
uas expert within the
department um I guess I'll I'll give
just a quick quick um brief overview um
for those who aren't familiar with our
office um we are the regulatory Agency
for all things aviation in the state um
we are the liaison to FAA for um pretty
much everything aircraft accidents uas
um airport development
so um I don't want to repeat what um
Tripper ball had said we we have worked
together um as a group um to develop
some language that would hopefully be
one of the firsts to to provide some
kind of guidelines to the use of uas um
uh full disclosure we we are a agency
that promotes Aviation so we are very
much involved with the education from
children's students all the way up and
and that is one of our charges so um
working together with uh these Partners
were to help to try to make it more safe
and and to allow law enforcement to have
some guidance on what they could do um
for those who are nefarious um and those
who tend to be repeat offenders so that
is our goal um we're here um we're here
to answer any of those questions I know
you had some questions um maybe some
technical questions we're happy to
answer those thank you very much
um everybody good we get it all covered
all right wow looks like you guys got
much is there anybody else here that
would like to testify on House Bill 468
that has not turned in paint card see
none I will close the public
hearing and
we are in are next hearing is at
that okay at this time we are going to
open the an executive session for House
Bill
162 and I would recognize representative
PR to make a
motion I don't
know wait I'm sorry I'm sorry I made him
it was the wrong wrong bill number I'm
so
sorry executive session for House Bill
698 oh that's someone else's that is
definitely okay um anybody want to make
a motion repres representative Murray I
make a motion to itl hey I'll second
that okay representative Murray would
you like to speak to your
motion um I think that this bill is
unnecessary and will interfere with law
enforcement's ability to execute their
duties representative appr would you
like to speak to your second
ditto does anybody have any
comments repres rep
schan I'm I know I know we chatted
before but I'm I I think it's I know we
just heard it wondering if we could
maybe do an amendment for it or but I
know there was some I think the Crux of
the matter is how how how would this
affect um
um off-duty cops responding to an
emergency and and um yeah I guess
yeah it's fine so representative one of
the I I think the sponsors intent is is
actually well heard and I I think I
speak for everybody when I don't think
that that fell on De ears I just don't
know that this is the avenue to address
the concerns that he had and and I'm
also not really sure what that Avenue
actually would be right um so if a
person that if an officer is an officer
and they're doing
something illegal and the intentions of
that something elicit that obviously is
illegal and and would need to be
addressed and I I'm very confident that
the leaders of those departments would
would handle that the best that they
could I really don't see how this could
be to be e could be executed at all but
I I might be
misunderstanding
um representative Shear is going to be
that this now I get to I could I talk
forever represent the floor is yours
representative Sher
um I think for for a few minutes anyway
I'm I'll be very brief I think this is
so poorly written that we have no idea
how it overlaps with uh 104 uh colon
28a uh which it's added to um and it uh
if there is a I'm still unclear what the
purpose of what he was trying to do is
if he's trying
to uh it's unclear to me whether he's
trying to prevent off-duty officers from
doing the kind of thing he the example
he gave of two people showing at
somebody's house and saying I'm an ice
agent um or whether he's trying to
prevent people who aren't law
enforcement in any way of doing that and
I don't think what the way it's written
it's even clear what she's trying to
address and that that's my problem with
it I would I would agree representative
representative
n thank you I think also just to add to
that it is very unclear it seemed pretty
duplicatus but also considering the fact
that it's that unclear anyone who are
guilty of this is guilty of a class be
felony which is a serious offense so at
the end of the day if we're going to be
saying that we're going to hold somebody
accountable much less law enforcement
accountable for you know for um um
something like this I think we really
need to be clear on what it is and I
think they need to be clear on what it
is I agree representative
Newman yeah I just want to comment in
the in the example that was given if two
people just show up and start asking
those questions and doing that this law
would not apply to them because they
would have to own a uniform that they
didn't
wear anybody else it followup would be
it's not a followup because I can talk
can it would not apply to in my opinion
it would not apply to the police because
those folks that don't own an official
uniform that they should wear they don't
have one so they wouldn't be subject to
the bill that's actually a very good
point representative Newman so if you're
impersonating you don't have the uniform
in the first place right so that that is
clearly a law that's this is not going
to to fix that's actually
a well stated actually um any anybody
else no more discussion representative
Murray thank you madam chair I was just
going to add um I believe it major Davey
who tested IFI that um you know ideally
so I think the sponsor was trying to
address one a one-off incident frankly
that you know we don't try to legislate
around you know oneoff instance but um
in that case I don't think we
necessarily have the jurisdiction to
like force the FBI to respond to this
inquiry if they weren't I know willing
to do so in person but I think the
concern was that if law enforcement like
valid law enforcement officials are
trying to execute a mission that is not
within their purview or execute um you
know UH responsibilities I guess that
are outside of their perview um and then
holding them accountable for that which
one I I don't think should be a class B
felony if that was the case I I think
it's more of what should be dealt with
is ensuring that there are internal
policies to address these circumstances
when they arise and that those policies
are being followed um which again I
think is a little bit more difficult
when we're talking about a federal
department or federal
agency if if I'm not mistaken I do think
that there is a bill that we're hearing
possibly next
week um actually it might be next 3:30
um that that I haven't read that bill at
all but just from the quick little
synopsis here that might be what it's
about and
um the the comment that we've heard a
few times about the example that was
given it is very unfortunate when you
actually know a person that that had a
wrong done to them right and generally
when you are that person that's had that
done you just kind of want to shout that
from the rooftops like you want
everybody to hear about this
Injustice and that that is unfortunate
and it's happened to every single one of
us I but I stand pretty firm I don't
think that this legislation is going to
address what that Injustice was at all I
wish it did but I don't think that it's
going to so um with that I believe we
are everybody good we're ready to go
ahead and take the vote all right the
clerk will call the role the motion is
itl for House Bill
698 Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative devoid yes
representative Pat yes representative
Sabor dwan yes representative Harriet
gright yes representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear
yes um that's it
120 motion of itl passes 120 and we will
close the executive session and we will
be in recess until 3:30 which will be
that I thank you for the reminder repres
resentative G rate everybody that would
go in the consent
calendar no okay no objection no
you
e
welcome back everybody um we are going
to open up our final hearing of the
day open up the hearing for House Bill
640 and we will
recognize um Prime sponsor is prime
sponsor here for
oh hold on wait I want to make sure I
say it right hold
on no repres I know I wrote it what is
it called fet pH
phonetically hooked on F Hooked on
Phonics that's what I had to do here
representative Sabor Sabor D
Schwaner good afternoon Madam chair
members of the committee I'm
representative saor Schwaner that was
really good um I didn't I didn't I
thought that this this kind of Bill
would actually be heard in front of
state federal relations and not criminal
justice but but here we are today um I'm
co-sponsoring of this I know
representative aan looks like he's the
prime looks like we got a lot of a lot
of co-sponsors on this bill what this
bill is about it's about it's an example
of federalism and ask oh and the private
sponsor is here now um we could I I'll
continue though it's about federalism
and and you know relative to the
transparency of federal agency
operations within New Hampshire and what
it's asking the Attorney General of the
State of New Hampshire to do is to
request that uh in point one federal
government agencies with law enforcement
investigatory or operational activities
in New hampsh should voluntarily provide
uh a list of data um as to what they are
doing in our
state um and how it's and then it's to
be
collected well thank you very much do
you want to just go ahead and yield and
we'll let representative Ammon uh
then Co I shall yeld to the prime okay
and then representative if you want to
if you would like to testify on the bill
we'll just have you come back up after
after he's done so he can yes ma'am all
that good afternoon representative Amon
youon my my printer ran out of ink so I
I emailed you my testimony I actually
just saw that come over so we do have
that thank you so I'm gonna cover what
was in
it all right for the record uh Friday
afternoon my name is Keith Aman
Hillsboro District 42 and I represent
the towns of New Boston Mount Vernon and
line
bro House Bill 640 before
you
is it's a it's a almost identical Bill
to House Bill 1411 from
2022 that was put in by William Foster
who's a constituent New Boston he he is
The Honorable William Foster um he was a
state representative in that
period House Bill 1411 passed the house
so an almost identical Bill to this one
passed the house on a Division vote
March of
2022 the vote was 204 to 134 so a pretty
good majority it went to the Senate and
the Senate uh ended up not passing it so
what I did was I looked at the Senate
testimony and I made some adjustments to
the bill based on the objection that the
Senate
heard and that's six House Bill 640
that's before
you House Bill 640 directs the Attorney
General to collect specific data from
federal agencies operating in our
state including the number of facilities
staff surveillance operations
investigations warrants arrests Refugee
relocations and Deport
pations this information would be
published quarterly in an aggregated and
anonymized form to protect
privacy a public website would feature
searchable database quarterly summaries
and annual
reports ensuring Clarity and
public so this bill is about
transparency and shedding light on
government
activities uh
improves transparency it improves the
citizens relationship with the
government
because uh we can see what they're doing
we understand to some degree what
they're
doing so it upholds the public right to
know empowers citizens with essential
information fostering more informed and
engaged community in New
Hampshire I want to note that the fiscal
note on this bill differs with the
fiscal note from 14 House Bill 1411 in
2022 to houseb 1411 fiscal note was
indeterminable this fiscal note suggests
that this bill would require three
positions for $230,000 a
year so given the the bill scope this
estimate to me seems
unreasonable and I would recommend that
this committee requests of the
Department of Justice to provide a
detailed
explanation for the investig ative
paralal legal assistant and attorney
require so just in
conclusion House Bill 640 would be a
prudent measure it aligns with New
Hampshire's tradition of
transparency it would equip citizens
with knowledge and strengthen trust in
government and I urge you to support
this bill it repes presents a vital
commitment to our democratic values and
questions representative
Shear do uh we the legislature have the
New Hampshire legislature have the power
to order the federal government to do
anything yeah this is not an order this
would be a request and part of the
report would be whether they gave us the
information or not right so okay that's
that would be part of the the report
any other
questions and I I did I when I walked in
I the the end of the bill talks
about the report would go to the state
federal
Relations Committee and
so
um that committee I think would be the
the appropriate committee for our
relationship with the federal government
but they would be informed about
activities thank you thank you
representative was just making a note of
the fiscal note that you were talking
about right I I don't see any questions
so thank you very much for coming in
today thank you and for the clerk I
emailed my testimony hold on one second
because I think the clerk just raised
her hand she does such a great job we
don't ever want to not give her her way
thank you madam chair uh I was just
going to ask and I might be missing it
is there um a frequency to when we're
requesting the report yes so House Bill
1411 which passed was monthly and this
bill it's quarterly so we reduced the
frequency which uh oh I see now thank
you
y we're
anyone is there anybody else here sir
did you want to testify on the bill okay
if you you can you're welcome to come up
if you could just make sure you felt the
pink card though uh before you leave so
that we have it for our
records if you could just please I when
you sit down just identify yourself and
there the button on mic
yeah you can bring it closer to you as
well if you need to you can just slide
it right up then you don't have to I
should need that or I should know that
um my name is William Foster I'm from
New Boston New Hampshire I am the uh
former rep that wrote
1440 and uh I wanted to test ify today
so you guys understand where this came
from
um I when I got into the legislature I
was assigned to the um to the
um foreign relations and Veterans Affair
committee and I uh was also speaking
with one of my
um constituents who talked to me a
little bit about the limited amount of
knowledge that we have you in the state
of what our federal government is
doing and so I started going down that
rabbit hole mostly because I wanted to
find out more about um what are federal
government's doing so that I would be
more useful with foreign relation or or
with Federal
relations
um as I went down that rabbit hole I
quickly discovered
that we have extremely limited knowledge
of what the federal government's doing
that is not centralized so that in order
to get it I have to literally go and ask
each and every agency in the federal
government for that
information and that because of the
supremacy clause they are under no
obligation to give me any information
whatsoever or they could give me limited
information and not include
everything and so in thinking of well
how can
we get more of that knowledge because in
re in reality the relationship we have
right now and the federal government is
one way um we have no idea and it's not
just us it's not just you as your your
representatives of your districts but
it's the Senate it's it's um every bit
of our state government all the way up
to the um Governor if the federal
government doesn't want to tell you they
don't have to tell you and I I I thought
that was unfortunate and and from a
completely um
non-political standpoint that's
unfortunate because
yeah as Representatives we want to try
to you know folks want to try to do
their best to represent
honorably um and so you would think that
as a representative of people you would
have nothing to hide and therefore hey
let's have transparency because
transparency develops trust and that's
something that's really lacking in our
government right now so I started
looking into it but there's very little
you can do I put together uh 1440 and I
did it on a monthly basis my goal wasn't
to
um infringe on any operation they're
doing or expose anybody's personal data
or any of that I literally just wanted
to know what they were doing so that we
could better plan at the state
level um and so I put it together
because no we can't for for some but we
can do one thing and that is
ask um and so I thought well let's ask
them for it now they don't have to give
it to
us we're not going to be sure that
they're giving us all the information
but at least we'll get some data points
and if they say we don't want to give
you anything that's a data point
also um I don't think that people the
vast majority of people in the state
understand the fact that they don't need
to tell us anything
and you may like the executive branch
that's in power right now or you may not
like the executive branch that's in
power right now either way they don't
have to tell you
anything um transparency to me is very
important as I say it it certainly grows
trust it allows us to see what folks are
doing yes we can ask them I think we
should ask them and I think we should
centralize that information I'm h oping
that this begins a discussion of just
how much the federal government is
telling us and what it's not so we could
possibly get transparency between the
two I think it would be much more
efficient if States knew what the
federal government was doing in them um
so I put it together Keith came and and
I talked with him and he I I thank him
very much I should say sorry
representative a I thank you very much
for bringing this up um it did pass the
house I had some family issues and I was
not able to walk it through the Senate
the way it should be so it didn't get
through I don't think that there's that
this is a partisan issue in any way
um I want to know what the federal
government's doing no matter who's in
power I want to know what effects
they're having on our state are they
doing things that we should be doing
instead of them we can't answer those
questions and will this Sol that problem
no but it is a very good step a very
small but good step in the right
direction of being able to say hey what
are they
doing and the information they share
could become very useful
to you folks as representatives of the
people so what I'm asking for is that
you pass it through
committee um as as as ought to pass I
would love to see it be something that
is is supported by both sides of the
legislature I think transparency is a
very good thing for um government as a
whole and I think it would be a good way
to start building back some trust in it
um so that's my
testimony any
questions thank you very much
representative
n thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question sure um I'm there are
a couple of things that I just wonder
kind of what it would look like in
practice one thing I know um you know
there's data that I like to follow
particularly overdose rates and and
things like that um because that's
something that I'm you know passionate
about um and I know that a lot of times
those things have a lag with them so
doing something quarterly I think would
I think it might be difficult in
practice um to have upto-date numbers so
even if you are reporting the numbers
you'd still be reporting on probably two
quarters ago or something like that but
um you know one of a couple of things
but I was just wondering what kind of
feedback you got from the Senate and and
what kind of things were addressed in
making the new and and coming up with a
new language as I said I had some family
issues I didn't get feedback from the
Senate but what I can tell you is this I
did put it in as as a monthly thing I
thought that would be be doable in
reality it could it's a list of
questions so it could be submitted by
the different we have a lot of agencies
in the federal government and there's 72
of them that have full-time armed people
that can come in conduct conve
surveillance um serve warrants and
arrest people without having to tell a
single person in our state government
about it so
um I put it in there at a monthly thing
the other thing you'll notice about the
questions is all the questions are what
did you do last quarter because the
second you say what are you doing
they're going to fall behind the we
don't discuss ongoing investigations we
don't discuss ongoing cases we don't uh
discuss our our
methodology so they they it gives them
if you try to ask them for current stuff
it will give them an excuse not to give
you anything can I ask a followup you
sure can I think some of these things as
well I would assume um um and I know in
some contexts they do I would I would
assume probably most um they would
coordinate with local police with local
law enforcement have you had any luck in
discussing it with local law enforcement
and have you gotten any feedback or
state police or any other well no and
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't they are not required to discuss
it with local law enforcement they're
not required to tell the Attorney
General of the state what they're doing
they can come in here and do whatever
they want and
literally go away and if you ask them
about it they can say we're not we have
no comment on
them and it's legal and I I think most
of you know that so well thank you do we
do representative Murray thank you madam
chair um just out of curiosity do you
have an idea of how likely these
agencies are to comply with these
requests CU I guess my concern would be
if we put this in statute you know that
the attorney general has to do this on a
quarterly basis and if they're not
providing you know what I mean like just
repetitively
well if they're not providing any
information that's a real quick data
point for them to enter no response all
it shows is hey this this this agency
has never responded or they haven't
responded in the last year or two years
or whatever so um I I I think that if
they don't respond it reduces the
workload to almost nothing anyways but
at least we have that data point right
now I can't tell you how many are going
to respond it's never been tried and we
don't know I know that you get a a a
assortment of responses if you reach out
to individual
agencies and there's a lot of agencies
so we wouldn't know follow it um I know
you've said that there are a lot of few
times do you know the number of agencies
not total agencies no I know that
there's over 70 agencies that have
full-time armed okay uh agents
that can operate within your state
without having to say word yeah just
thinking about the time it would take to
request all that I think it's the actual
number I think the last time I looked
was
so so so if I may ask a question so
basically what
you're what you would like is somebody
in the Attorney General's office to type
something up that says hey how many
agencies are in New Hampshire and have
them list what those are and then what
what they not what they're going to do
what they what they did not their
intentions of what they did and then if
they just don't answer then they just
don't answer like do we know who they
would even send it
to God bless you that would be someone
in the Attorney General's office okay so
okay yeah I just personally and this is
the last you know well not the last but
this is this is what I will testify to I
think it is is ridiculous
that the that there is no centralized
point for a representative or a senator
a legisl a legislate from the state of
New Hampshire to go and find out what
the federal government's doing within
the
exist any other
questions seeing no further questions
thank you very much much thank you is
there anybody else that is here wishing
to testify on House Bill 640 that is not
turned in a pain card seeing none I will
close the public hearing and we are
finished with our business for the day I
believe we're back
on wedness day he's doing it right now